you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes I hear that Bell and I'm ready to
fight Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up
they want the boat they don't work
enough don't mess around and I'm hurting
them I say the wrong thing make it
personal you say the wrong thing I might
hurt yeah what's up fam welcome welcome
to very special special episode of
combat's fight campaign we are joined by
the pound for pound best fighter on
planet Earth over there the most
entertaining man on the planet his music
no all no no shade here at all his music
is fire it is my brother from a very
very pretty mother thank you and also
not thank you don't talk about my mama
well you know you you only call her I
don't say from a very you know uh heavy
mother you know you want let's restart I
wasn't feeling good yeah let's do it
let's redo this intro but I never get
nervous doing this live
no I've been doing it so long and I
think uh the steaks don't even wrong
they're high but it's not like a steak
like uh like doing a Rogan companion
where you know there's like whatever 10
million listeners and I came up on that
platform so it's like with him and I and
I I think yeah I think I'm the only one
Rogan had to work and had to cancel the
companion was like can you can you just
do it for me can you host it so I sat in
his chair I figured who else was on the
show it was that I was like filling in
for him and that that felt like pressure
so this is so he wasn't even there for a
show no he was like Hey dude I forget
what I know you're running [__] bro I
figured what happened he's like hey can
why don't you do it I'm like what okay I
gotta go count my money I think it's the
only time anybody's ever filled in for
Road you know how when Ellen misses like
when Ellen used to miss back in the day
and then you tune in it's like I don't
know like Howie Mandel everyone's like
oh okay well it's not Ellen you know
that's how I felt were you more nervous
about the Rogan takeover or you fighting
in the UFC fighting the UFC like this
whatever you you flip some words you
mess up it's all good baby you know it's
like in the UFC you get knocked out in
your underwear in front of millions of
people those are from dark days and you
get half your pay do you ever have
random thoughts while you're in there
you just like fight oh yeah really oh
yeah especially early on I remember it
was one of the biggest fights ever I
remember I saw Hulk Hogan I remember
this look I'm like holy [__] that's the
Hulk star man I was like oh you got
distracted by Hulk yeah Hulk Hogan yeah
Hulk Hogan yeah yeah did you win or lose
uh I won that one let's go against
Gabriel Gonzaga yeah against the
hulkster now
um Ryan Garcia canceled on us the king
himself canceled on us not his fault
it's a flight issue we thought he'd be
making it on time but I sent out the bat
signal and I don't know if you know
who's filling in from this in this chair
for Ryan Garcia but he is the greatest
135er to ever walk this Earth it is
Dominic Cruz they're gonna be a better
fill-in so Dom when Ryan canceled I text
Dom like yo I don't know if because he's
you he's an analyst with UFC he's
currently he's not retired yet but maybe
he has one more but he's one of the top
analysts for the UFC so I figured he's
maybe working maybe they flew him out to
Jersey to work the desk or something
like that and I was like yo where are
you he's like San Diego I'm like dude
how fast is your car he's like why I'm
like cuz you got about two hours if you
could get to come do the fight campaign
with him he's like say less really like
what really you're in he's like yeah
dude I'll see you soon and text me just
him on the road just fly so he'll be
here uh probably come about 20 minutes
after the hour here but we're gonna you
give him a little bit about this yeah
dude please do feel free just teach him
some technique because he he likes that
too he's a he's not prickly at all but
he uh he's probably the one of the best
Minds in the game as well hey so I'm
gonna I'm gonna to be honest when he
gets here I'm gonna pretend like I
really know everything about this sport
yeah and everything he says I'm gonna
disagree with yeah
you know what I like George I like for
the entertainment value there couldn't
be a worse guy to do it he's the best
but he's he's uh no [__] type but
dude I'm Gonna Keep such a straight face
like he's like yeah you know he he's
great you're gonna be like great combos
I was like nah you should be like I
think you're off on this he's a little
slow tonight though these combos are
good I think McDonald's has better
combos he's the perfect guy for the gig
cuz last night uh and I was actually
there I just flew in
um one Championship had uh Demetrius
Johnson Mighty Mouse who's the goat
pound for pound goat so he fought last
night and tonight is the championship
fight for bantamweight at 135 with Al
Jermaine Sterling Henry sahudo so
there's not a better guy in the world to
break this down for us I actually want
to ask some questions
because maybe some of your viewers have
no idea why is everybody pound for pound
the best every time I hear somebody's
name well hold on now no down for pound
and that's the words and by the way when
you hear pound for pound you can't argue
because the pounds have been weighed
well yeah it's like ranking superheroes
like they're not it's not real it's not
a real list no one what so so the guy
who beat up Conor not pound for pound
uh khabib yeah uh there's a debate
that's that's the problem there's a
debate so my pound for pound if you want
to go down this road I would love to
let's go okay my pound for pound number
one be uh Jon Jones just because of oh
well a level of difficulty he's actually
undefeated and also he fights at a
higher weight class so his his uh margin
for air is so much smaller feet ziggs
when he should have zagged he gets
knocked out Mighty Mouse you can say it
Mighty Mouse khabib they have a little
more room to to have some errors and not
get finished John and John you look at
his resume it's nachos and how many
times he defended the belt so khabib he
just didn't do it long enough he so
dominant though most dominant guy we've
ever had but didn't do it long enough
like a Jon Jones The Mighty Mouse would
do it for a hot second and then
defending titles in the UFC defend
titles in one Championship he's a Savage
man who controls this computer
can I see Mighty Mouse yeah
great dude great dude as a human being
or a fighter uh as a human being yeah
really good person oh okay okay you know
this guy right yes so Mighty Mouse uh
why do they call him Mighty Mouse you
know he's Mighty Mouse you know the
cartoon
how old are you 40. I grew up on Mighty
Mouse really is that I'm guessing it's
Mickey Mouse no dude Mickey Mouse some
trash uh Mickey Mouse for hoes no wait
wait there's a different mouse that was
popular dude but Mighty Mouse could
actually kick ass you know Mickey's like
all woke now like hey look at me or
whatever well let's uh let's I'm gonna
retract from his statement because
Disney owns everything okay oh dude I've
had my issues with Disney dude you can't
even say their name right they literally
took it I can't yeah they'll charge me
every time I say it I am a huge fan of
Disney I like to go to Disney twice a
year and I spend tons of money there I'm
a season ticket holder okay
of a season pass because you have kids
yeah but I'm an adult just go if you
have a season pass an adult you
pedophile right no not true
again don't put me in that [__] box
so that's my mess he was a battle this
is addiction kicked ass but that looks
like Demetrius Johnson that's what I
said because he's smaller yeah small and
Powerful yeah pretty much because you
know uh Demetrious Johnson's small so
they call him Mighty Mouse but he
thought last night I was live in
Broomfield Colorado dude the one
championship event I'm sure talking
about with dom too but that one
championship event unreal like the card
finishes finishes finishes finishes gets
to the main event we're like here we go
it's a Trilogy fight they both have one
win over each other I'm like here we go
not not fireworks it was like the It Was
a Very tactical fight but not exciting
it was like oh when was this it was last
night
I just got back in town it was in uh my
hometown in Denver nothing's worse than
a boring fight the my problem with that
it's tough because it's really tactical
but I think what the the rest of the
card was Unreal dude like finish
knockout submission finish Non-Stop and
then you get to the main event like oh
dude here we go and then that was the
one that was lackluster it's just and
it's late too like damn I'm tired now
watching fights and watching like human
beings cheer on another human being to
beat the [__] out of another weird it's
not only weird but it reminds me like
we're half doing it back in the day they
waited until the person died now I just
feel like you're half-assing it yeah
agree I mean like the Champion's the
champion because he still has a beating
heart true
you and you want to go back to those
roaming Gladiator days where like
caesar'd be like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Geeks are [__] because he gives
everybody thumbs up like what can you do
there was no unanimous decision they
both no
no do you have to be bald to have a
microphone
wow yeah that's a good point they are
all
um lost their hair yeah you know don't
they say it's a high it's a high
testosterone thing right broken yeah
Rogan looks like he's lost some lbs
are you saying that because he's your
friend
no he's usually like no he probably
wouldn't like me saying that he's
usually like like beefier he looks like
he's leaning out now Muhammad he's a
middle eastern brother of yours uh you
know he looks like a French Montana
a little bit he looks like he's about to
drop a guy in a beat at the same time
this dude is a his groundwork is insane
yeah yeah he's a Savage and he's also a
guy who like he's of he's like the
hardcores want him to get the next title
shot so next title shot is Kobe
Covington and Leon Edwards but most
people think the winner of Gilbert Burns
and
um blail Muhammad should get the title
shot because they both deserve it
especially balil is on like what an
eight fight win streak or something like
that chin right I I think uh so he got
some no cards I have no cards Dude so
like when I got invited to this dude
yeah the first question I had was first
of all like why me but then I was like
you know what no I love you you're great
because you but also you know like these
don't get me wrong like
when it's like my like if it's other
comics and if it's Fighters and it
depends sometimes sometimes Comics they
get tense here and I have to do all the
heavy lifting you know it's just like no
bro not I want to have fun not me with
you hour early you can I did come an
hour early I was like they go hey George
here already go why
I thought people were gonna be here I
was very uh respect I actually started
touring his studio with his neighbors
he's never met yeah hopefully the guy's
cool yeah and if he steals your [__]
it's not mine yeah
um so okay so I went down when I when I
got the call I immediately went and I
watched each one of these Fighters and
how they fought okay so you did some
research oh all of them I watched all
their fights you got some questions no
no questions I have I'm gonna let you
know who my picks are oh I love it yeah
yeah for the main card yeah yeah for all
okay so check us out but let's start an
order right with the Jessica and yan yan
yon Yan yep so yawns so from okay this
is again I don't [__] watch UFC too
much but you looked into it but I'm good
at reflecting [__] okay when I was
reflecting these two fighters I think
that Jess is going to win and I'll tell
you why I think she has great hands and
she's dangerous with Guillotines yeah
Yan has great combos but from watching
her I don't think there's power behind
them she has good kicks and she's very
aggressive but she has no ground and
Jessica can hit Jessica can hit I dig
that so you're taking Jessica taking
Jessica on that is Jen is just let's see
compare this is just a slight favorite
I think she is she is now yeah now he
probably moved the line a lot of people
were like I understand that Middle
Eastern like it makes sense dude
if you go against uh Blair Mohammed
though you're gonna you'll be catching
some heat oh I did he's not winning
tonight oh wow I think you would see
this gonna beat his [__] oh we disagree
with this I'll tell you why
I think he has better hands
he has more power I'd say I think he has
better hands now because he's been
working on his hands and I think they're
better and on top of that I think if it
goes to the ground it's done it's a fair
point if it goes to the ground with his
Jiu Jitsu it'd be a long day in the
office dude I'm doing pretty awesome how
are you doing really well I'm doing
pretty good yeah is like a
there's like three different ones here
uh well one's over under the rounds and
then so
um yeah so Jessica androg is a mighty
one said she's the favorite bullyo
Mohammed I think is the best pick on the
card is a plus 130 so slight dog Gilbert
Burns is minus 150 so Gilbert Burns to
speed his third time fighting in like
what is it four months something nuts
and he thought wow three weeks ago he he
wants to smoke yeah nuts what are you
laughing at you no he's just idiot he's
very soon yeah yeah yeah who do you
think's gonna win uh the main card uh or
the main event so I so I like your pick
so far do you want to hear mine before I
encourage yours decision go ahead bud
Sterling
why Sterling it's even money right now
minus 110. I think his ground game is
way stronger yes so as we get your back
so I think what he's going to do is try
to take him to the ground because hold
on Henry has a really fast right hand
from what I've been watching yeah and so
I don't think he's going to want to
outbox him little cat little little can
I just put a little post this no post a
note thank you for asking I know and
you're like I'll see you know I'll take
it for a minute
gold medalist and Olympics wrestling no
that's totally fine but he's not beating
him you know why no I agree I'm picking
aljo but I don't but it's gonna be tough
to take him down I think aljo's gonna
have to somewhere in the transition well
so who to maybe take him down and
attempt to take down get his back but
it's gonna be tough to get to Judo down
dude but if anybody can do it and
there's something about this bro and
listen I've been doing this for quite
some time
no I really think uh I think it's not
bad dude
right for somebody I'm not gonna put
this together but you know what I
appreciate you actually put some effort
in and looked into it thank you bro yeah
I'm here to perform yeah we've had some
people on there like so uh is Canelo on
this y'all well he's fighting today
though he is fighting yeah he always
fights uh Cinco de Mayo Cinco de Mayo he
always fights well it's not Cinco de
Mayo I know but he fights that weekend
like that's the Mexican
Super Bowl are you Mexican no everyone
thinks I am though life would be easier
if I was
a Mexican no are you sure yeah tell your
face that bro what's up you you look
Mexican you look like an Italian guy
that's trying to
be Mexican yeah yeah no are you Italian
splash of Italian mainly what the [__]
are you I'm German right okay
sprechenzie Deutsch German then my mama
born raised in England have 50 English
are you sure promise man unless my
unless the was it 23 means lying to me
wasn't your special called Gringo poppy
yeah I gotta go
it comes after Mexicans and Disney I
don't know if I should be on this
program anymore
so this one's interesting because it's
Chrome Gracie who's the great Gracie
right
so Gracie started I mean
it's the Gracie family the Jujitsu
Legacy Gracie Chrome Gracie who's this
guy this is a guy that is Jordan yeah
Charles Jordan This is the next fight
yeah this is the start of the main card
this is the first five in the main card
it's Chrome Gracie who's a straight
Grappler versus Charles Jordan who's a
straight Striker how come I didn't
I'll tell you right the night
let's say Dom shows up an hour late all
good George is here let's say uh none of
my picks are right all good my boy Matt
Steamroller for Rolla one dude awesome
beat Drew Drew Dober which is a huge win
yeah you already saw it you're excited
about us stoked I wanted to get that win
good dude really good dude
so our boy Charles Jordan's coming off
two losses here Shane Burgos nothing to
hang ahead about Nathaniel wood all
right
yeah this is typical uh this is like old
school UFC you've got a straight
Grappler versus a straight Striker it's
like whoever
implements their game plan better is
going to get the win
but for Chrome Gracie uh Casey chin do
you guys watching She's the grappler I'm
guessing yeah he's a striker he's the
striker yeah
gotcha did you see the embeddeds and
like the countdowns right Chrome's not
messing around but even in the press
conference very 10 10 questions maybe 40
seconds of answers nope he's like angry
it's like a chip have you seen him with
the sudo when they're signing the he
just doesn't like the he doesn't play
games yeah so sahuda thought he hated
sahuto yeah he was like ah okay but he's
like he's a weight cut so he understands
why he's like being a little difficult
being like kind of mess up towards
sahudo but uh yeah I don't know
and so uh just so you know George so uh
Chrome Gracie hasn't fought since 2019
so he's taking three years off in his
last fight so he's undefeated then
fought Cub Swanson was absolute Savage
he decided to stand with Cub Swanson and
his striking is not his Forte right he's
a Jitsu Phenom but he decided to stand
with kept Swanson and got pretty beat up
bro I'm having such a brain fart and I
don't I'm really bad with names but
there's an Assyrian UFC fighter
Syrian I it starts with a B I don't know
why I'm
douche man oh my God thank you oh
one more time for me banil Darius
Savage why isn't why are they not
promoting him more uh
he's
that's a good question and it shouldn't
work like this but he's super religious
so I knew they're crippling him because
he loves Jesus it's not that it's just
like
um
it's hard to explain because his resume
is phenomenal he's fighting Charles
Oliver next what is his views matter
everybody goes up you know why God I
agree but you know what happens is I
could get a he's a such a Savage he's
training monster but he would get he
gets a win they give him like to who do
you want next he's like I don't care all
you know all glory to God like no we got
that no he's not playing the game you
don't play the game he doesn't care so
he's not asking for a title shot he does
not care he's like whoever God wants to
fight next it's like I know but so
that's business that they're coming
after but what about the score of being
an actual good athlete does that not say
enough see and a purist would agree with
you so it's same reason why uh Muhammad
should be getting the tile shot he
didn't even have to fight your Burns he
should have the title shot but he's
another guy who and he's different he's
entertained speaks well I don't get
understand him but they're giving
another guy and Kobe Covington I don't
feel Kobe Covington who's like super pro
Trump talks all the [__] but it's all
like WWE style because after the nice
guy ever worked his ass off great person
put a camera on him he turns in this guy
you're not gonna so they want to promote
people that are selling tickets that's
not a bad thing no it's because remember
it's also entertainment so wait how come
nobody came up to him and been like hey
man we really love your views but do you
mind calling somebody out first and then
going to like because he's like no
that's not that's not in my nature which
I love
the respect because that's his this is
his style of I think they respect it and
they give him a huge fight in Charles
Oliveira they respect it but there's
other guys are going to jump over you
that might have more Instagram followers
or a bigger YouTube following I watched
the clip of Dana White saying he doesn't
care he doesn't like it when people
think is God he's like listen it's not
what they're here to watch
so would you say he has like a vendetta
against people that do that I just think
he knows that for the majority of the
fight like fan base unfortunes like call
somebody out and tell me you're gonna
rip their head off I don't like it
either but it's just the nature of the
game like it became this very wwe-ish
like fake call out because Connor did it
but it was natural to Conor it's in his
DNA they're showing clones of Conor but
there's no Conor right now there will
never be another Connor but there's guys
that feel like oh well Connor's has all
this Fame and got all these title shots
and all these privileges so let's do
what he does but it's not natural Dome
and the fan base can smell it a mile
away so they're punishing people like
him not punish him because if he beats
Charles Oliver he's in your next title
shot he just has to win his next one but
he should uh uh your boy your your boy
um uh Darius but Neil Darius she just
has to win his next one he'll get the
tall shot they just make how old is he
though is he getting up in age they're
used yeah he is he's been in the sport
for a hot second
because bro I've been hearing about
derouche for so much 33 and he deserves
so much more respect than what he's
getting oh dude and I'm not just saying
that because I'm a Syrian like I'm only
speaking up because I'm Assyrian I feel
like I have to do my due diligence with
this guy this guy needs more love yep
everyone everyone Community loves him
but the the the promotion doesn't like
give him the chance
you know who he wants to fight next Dana
White yeah no he starts starting up [__]
first he's just one of those guys where
it's like they're just their path is
different like some guys get catapulted
in the stardom because they talk the
talk and they back it up a little bit
and you know he's like we can make money
off this with banil all the skill sets
first of all world class Jiu-Jitsu
player world-class striker
Granite change wrong chin bro oh my God
he gets hit and he just sees rest and
he's like a bull dude yeah he's knocked
out artist yeah he's just missing the
other X Factor that unfortunately in
2023 the UFC promotes more of that than
to be honest you have to become
undeniable and that's what if he wins
this I feel like he is I mean he hasn't
lost yet correct no he has he's lost
before but but he hasn't lost in a hot
second look at those dude look one two
three four five six seven eight wins
you beat Tony Ferguson where are you
looking at okay got yourself the greens
wins I was looking up here so many
screens but please become undeniable
because he wins this next one and
they're gonna have to give to him
especially at 55. yeah but that's fine
it has to take a long road it's the
hardest Road he but he's taking the
right road because the other thing is by
the time he gets there he knows in his
heart of heart he's beat all the
challengers anybody else can come get it
he's he's gonna be truly the chance
people are gonna have to come to him
correct and and it's not like some of
these other guys that don't deserve a
tie shot they happen to get it but they
don't keep it long by the time douche
gets it he's going to hang on to it
because he's walked the fire
but but uh Darius and also
if you do a fight companion 100 I want
to be here for that yeah you better buy
his [__] shirt
I actually have them all that makes
sense I don't have them all you have a
fight kid but I'm gonna start wearing
all of his merch great dude man bro I
remember when I was in like Arizona bro
like he put air he put Assyrians on on
his back dude everybody who like a
Sirens didn't like they're not
in the top of all of these Sports
he's not getting his love
the the syrians rally around him though
is he big in the community there
Assyrians yeah I mean he's like the king
bro he's the guy right I mean well yeah
he's the guy who's putting everybody on
yeah yeah there's nobody else Assyrian
wise yeah no but also I agree that
nobody else not even a sharing wise
could take him out right now no he's a
Monster yeah and he he matches up well
with Charles Oliveira he should get it
done but um let me ask you this like in
in with syrians and uh syrians syrians
there's cesarean there's syrians and
then Assyrians oh syrians you're a
Syrian yeah and the religion why is the
religion there it would be Christian
Yeah we actually spoke the language
Jesus spoke it's not Muslim no no we
were Jewish before Jewish people forgive
my ignorance is why is that part of the
world not Muslim because the surrounding
areas are Muslim correct so we are like
Heritage goes all the way to Abraham so
when Abraham was like an Assyrian
Babylon so like when that like okay
Jonah went to to go save the Assyrians
so the guy that got eaten by the big
fish yeah was to save the syrians the
syrians grew to be in the Jewish family
and that's why our alphabets are the
same oh we're and then so when Jesus
came there was like a split some people
decided to still become Jews and then
some people found him to be the God and
so they became Christians in that part
of the world is it the only Christian we
don't have a country anymore
yeah we're we we're like we're just kind
of couching it on other people's
countries yeah just kind of Crash it
yeah just crashing on people's couches
Christian crap but you you throw a
Christian in the party bro I mean a
Christian you throw a cereal into the
party we'll get it started bro you get
started very alcohol-free you're gonna
start though I just don't like alcohol
bro people drink to have confidence I
feel like I have too much confidence
if I drink I'll just become an [__]
no well some people drink to have
confidence and some people just drink
because they enjoy half problems some
have problems with it or some people
they're real shy so yeah like it gives
them confidence like you I'm super shy
you're very sure I'm not I'm a such an
introvert dude I see girls like my hands
get sweaty I just can't
or I'm an alcoholic I just love the
flavor
who do you got on this fight uh Crone's
my guy it's not going great for him you
know but uh I'm hoping Crone wins and in
his Chrome Gracie let's look at that bro
from the Gracie family his Day the movie
was out like at least four years ago why
are they still on their pants how much
money did they have what movie Venom is
that dude God bless you so when you talk
about fightings like me talking about
Christianity so um is that not the movie
no no Venom is a brand of uh gear for
Combat Sports and it's spelled different
it's spelled
v-e-n-u-m and it's a French in my
defense I can't read and they're moving
a lot so I agree and the logo when it's
black and white looks like Venom the
movie that has Tom Hardy in it it does I
was like I just had a really big budget
for that movie bro let's keep going man
they're part three coming up
Prime all over
available in Walmart now
yep I knew uh Logan's gonna make money
on that because my son's soccer team
like the certain parents after bringing
snacks and drinks for the games and
they're like their eighth game and uh
I brought you know [__] like Hi-C and
Capri Suns when I was a kid capri suns
were lit dude if I had a Capri Sun they
didn't even make them bigger first of
all the the is that the silver pouch and
you you still drink that who doesn't
it's cool you gotta respect the pouch
yeah but dude they're so small they're
so small it's a disaster so I whatever I
brought Capri Suns because I'm an
awesome guy these kids were like where's
the prime my son was like God damn it
what they just they and I was like oh oh
oh he's that's another level he tapped
into the market kids are like where's
the prime you son of a [__] I'm like
you're seven oh he's making all the
money now you know it's like do you
remember
um when they made the big pouches though
do you remember that
but if you look it up like
I'm now if you tell me dunkaroos come in
a bigger bag I'm gonna freak out could
you look up Capri Sun big pouch oh I'm
sorry I'm looking around yeah kill
priest sound Capri Sun uh extra large
pouch
bonus pouch
what
dude did I say discontinued no I told
you super Sun big told you bro
game changer
330 milliliters
they discontinued oh mother
but we've discontinued the big pouches I
love how there's these two grown men
like risking their lives
[Laughter]
dude Capri Sun went big because
everyone's complaining it was the same
thing when I was a kid I loved those uh
oatmeal pies but they were like this big
oatmeal pies yeah is that a breakfast
thing uh it was a little Debbie
um uh is it a sweeter it's a sweet it's
like two sauce off oatmeal cookies with
ice in the middle they're this big dude
so when I was a bigger kid my mom put
one I'm like Mom what are you doing now
you wasting my time I'm like put at
least two to three oh for your life you
buy a box so they're like say less we
hear you little fat boy
oh dude um you get that middle that
sweet soft nectar in the middle bro Game
Changer I uh my mom was the type of mom
that would over pack for me I barely ate
and she would like over pack and so what
I did is I always was in trouble in
school always like I was always in
suspension like in art like I don't feel
like you're like the Troublemaker were
you religious back then too no I wasn't
Gathering people being like let's all
turn to James and Grace
they're like hey they call your man I'm
like we feel like George is starting a
cold
he's learned them in with big pouch
Capri Suns no I used to get in trouble
for just talking and like I had ADHD so
like when I went to the bathroom I
didn't come back for like 15 minutes
because they had all this decorations on
the wall and I would just stare at them
and I'll just get like taking that out
yeah so I got I the
I forgot what it's called detention
detention was after school so that you
would be in detention after school and
then you would take that bus that the
football kids would take yeah and so
what I did is I told my mom I'll be like
you make extra extra because now I'm
going to be after school for another
hour yeah and come out in two hours
later I would sell the sandwiches to the
football players dude because they were
starving entrepreneur hey boys you look
pretty hungry over there who wants a
carrot
is it like tasty treats or was it like
something no sandwiches my mom would
make like bomb sandwiches all like ham
and cheese sandwiches oh my God like the
most incredible homemade sandwiches
right now your mom still doesn't yeah
well I bet your mom can cook oh second
time you brought up my mom man I know
dude I'm starting to get a little
uncomfortable right that's the only
reason I brought you here yeah you don't
make sense I don't like fighting I'm
like I know I won't talk to your mom I
think the only reason I did stand up is
because uh my mom cooked for Joe Coy
like multiple times yeah dude Joko is a
good one no no I mean I'm literally
talking at three o'clock in the morning
oh wow we would come after a show and my
mom would have this spread on the table
like three four in the morning would be
and then Joe would just come over always
love it he's such a family human being
oh such a good person oh one of the best
he's been in this house in Vegas
many times and it's beautiful not so
he's doing it right yeah doing it right
he and he has like multiple he's a very
intelligent human being Wick get smart
and they went Hollywood he went to
another level in Hollywood you know
Comics said when they get to Hollywood
it's like dude different Stratosphere
what I love is that he kept his humor I
felt like there's a lot of I'm not going
to mention any names because it's live
we can't beep it but I've like there's a
few comedians are like when I'm learning
about their legacy I could I could tell
that they changed well because the
game's different because back in the day
a lot of comics would do stand up
because they know big time studio
Executives would be in the crowd and
they were just doing stand-up to get
that sitcom or get the movie and then as
soon as they went Big Time movie Big
Time sitcom they never went back to
stand up really it's different now now
some of the guys like you know Bill Burr
does movies but Bill's love and passion
he's never going to leave it so he
doesn't let it affect his stand-up but
back in the day it was like they were
just doing stamp just to get that big
movie deal just get the TV deal but
there's guys like that now where like
there's again I won't mention names
where they have so many projects like
movies like it's like there's no way
you're riding like there's no way or you
have a team riding for you always
there's no big No-No to mention that
they have writers
Kevin Hart's pretty open about it he's
the one he's all one of the only guys at
his level that go you have writers
what's up
he just said what's up yeah you're like
okay but he's still funny as [__]
because it's he has writers that are so
close to him and they're they're part of
basia's family and they know what he's
going through and they're like what
about this premise and then he'll run
from there but they give him ideas but
he's very open about it who do you think
is the best stand-up comedian on the
Earth right now Bill Burr or uh Bill
Burr Bill Burr hands down or uh Louis
C.K so there's a it's like the the uh
pound for pound list it's all you know
whoever you think is better but there's
no real list so it's either Bill Burr
Dave Attell uh I think big J orkson uh
right now Big J's doing it his last
special the best special I've seen in a
hot second
um uh Louis CK
you like them twice you put him on twice
so I Bill Burr Louis CK David tell Big J
orkerson
um
no one makes you laugh harder than Theo
oh man I Theo's dudes Theo was something
else when I was like we had him on the
podcast and then talking to him in real
life and this might just be me but I
feel like I'm talking to a character I
don't know if it's actually him he might
be doing around his stand-ups ridiculous
he's so funny he might be funnier than
just casual conversation yeah and I
think that's why that's slowly coming
over to him in a stand-up and it's like
once and he's ridiculous now like I
caught him when he was on fire oh my God
it was something else when he caught
wind and you could see when a comedian
catches wind bro I watched him put out
everybody else's fire that was a monster
oh he was unbelievable
good
I know it's not going well for Chrome is
it boys
he has to land a takedown terrible
though but yeah yeah it's just this day
and age the the MMA has evolved so much
where you can't just unless it's
wrestling outside that you can't just be
dominant in one aspect of the sport
otherwise you get found out and don't
get me wrong it's no shade on Charles
jourdain but you know he's not like a
top 15 guy well I thought you just said
no shade it's but it's just but it's
also just facts like he's not top 15
yeah you know would you beat him in a
UFC fight right now yes yes I would take
him down and choke him unconscious
yeah they are they are very small though
yeah what are they 145 150 uh
featherweight's 145.
lightweight would be 155. what are they
in featherweight oh they are 140 145. so
they probably walk around maybe 160. I
have 100 pounds on them it's not cool
you think I get hate now put me in a
featherweight fight and see what happens
oh look he's complaining
yeah for Cronus you know it took three
years off so that long layoff's tough
and it's just the sport evolved so much
man it's still pretty new so and guys
are so damn technical now they're so
good
you can't just be good at Jiu Jitsu you
think the UFC is going to be around much
longer oh yeah yeah I don't know they
have this really cool slapping thing
coming out that is the stupidest thing
I've ever seen in my life you know what
it is though I I was talking about this
last night with uh actually I spoke
about with chatri who's the owner of one
championship and uh my coach uh Amal
Easton who I got my black belt from
we're talking about slap Fight League
and I would I actually found myself
defending Dana White a little bit which
is rare because
he saw online the views and the
spectacle and being like dude some of
these slaps you know that aren't marked
like I can do are getting millions of
views I bet there's a opportunity to
make money off this and turn the route I
agree but it's this capability of this
agree but this is where you
miscalculated he assumed that Tick Tock
and Instagram equals a true sport that
people want to watch for an hour we
consume it and once you see a slap 15
seconds I'm good I don't see that for an
hour you know what I'm saying it's like
it's a stupid idea but the things that
go viral on there doesn't mean it's
gonna be good for TV so it's like yeah I
watch an Anaconda eat an alligator I
don't watch an hour of anacondas eating
I don't know I could probably watch that
for an hour for an hour just but slow
I'm talking slow and then and then after
30 minutes it's like one more you know
you're like God damn I'm just gonna keep
going you know like the slap it's like
there's no uh there's no Talent behind
it no zero there's none my favorite and
the one that I watched was dirty as [__]
the refs we're training one of the guys
that was in it yeah that was dirty I
don't know if that's going to be in
there but the TBS canceled their uh
plans for it and that's with Rumble but
it's also what's funny about that is I
think six of the competitors why they're
drug test them I have no clue like I
want my slap fighters on meth and
steroids
take meth by the way recently I'm sorry
I think I stay up all night I didn't
know about that that makes me drive past
them so much faster yeah but not all
because my grandpa and uh Uncle truck
drivers for 50 years now 100 they don't
do math 100 then he's the thickest
method I've ever seen in my life
what is this what's your boy doing bro
tell him to get up he wants him to come
to the ground you know that's what he
wants we're not paying you to sit down
get up man I'm gonna get grilled no
this just looks like somebody's beating
up somebody at a park yeah it's just
because when you can't get the guy down
it's easier to learn take down defenses
he's really crawling with his butt
cheeks right I love this he just wants
to get down surprise that ref who's they
definitely oh he just told him to get up
that ref they definitely usad is not
testing that ref right that ref is yeah
he's all shoulders yeah
um did you have a roid while you were
fighting or you're not a lot wish I
[__] wish I could so wait I would
have done it so do Fighters roid before
they have to get like tested or
something that was different because
when I was fighting they didn't have
asterisk testing like you got tested the
week of the fight now it's usada which
is random drug testing so if you're
under the UFC contract let's say you had
a fight scheduled for December end of
the year 2023 yeah they and they found
out you're here they're gonna come test
you right here so they test you four in
the morning two in the morning well then
why don't people go train in different
countries they follow them to different
countries yeah you can't go off grid no
no
if you go off grid it's labeled as a
failed uh test and you're screwed you
get suspended happened to uh one of the
Diaz they can't get a hold of him I
guess fail test
do you think heroids no not at all he
doesn't he looks the one that you guys
ever defend that that don't do it but
the rest of them you know with usada
it's tough man it's very tough to get
away with it but who's the one that got
caught doing steroids in the USA oh man
uh Chael sonen uh Jon Jones but actually
he actually kind of uh that kind of got
revoked but Jon Jones for a while but uh
TJ Dillashaw got caught with EPO uh
Anderson Silva's been caught
chelseonan's like our Lance Armstrong if
you know who tells so if you get caught
with it are you banned from the UFC
two-year suspension is that why Silva
was gone for so long uh I don't think he
got two years off would Silva get to you
remember but silver got caught uh Vitor
Belfor Alistair Overeem uh Brock Lesnar
didn't get wait wait Brock Lesnar's in
the UFC used to be
used to be yeah phenomenal athlete too
like what he did in a short amount of
times insane one of the best combats
definitely Roy's yeah of course he does
and that's why there's a lawsuit against
Mark hunt and him so one year and by the
way it's not it's off-grid like it's
just tougher to test them when they're
like say like they're in Thailand or
they'll get them though in Thailand
they'll get him yeah but it's just
tougher to do it so it's just they know
how to work the system if you're gonna
cheat
real quick Anderson Silva got a one-year
system one year two years like usually
pretty like you're just taking Deca from
Gold's Gym
the
there was a kid in my school and I dude
it's so funny we're bringing this up my
last trip to Arizona he ran into me and
him and his football friends would
always ask me to pee in a Five Hour
Energy drink why because they knew I
don't do any drugs so I was like the kid
that was very like off drugs off
drinking and they needed me to pee in a
Five Hour Energy drink because they
would be able to put that in their life
like their boxer brief so when they walk
in to go get tested oh they just popped
open that cap and they just
and then ironically 10 years later I
dated a girl whose Uncle ran the Five
Hour Energy drink so I'm so sick that
uncle's balling
I know somebody came out waiting to date
a billionaire yeah is he a billionaire
until somebody came out with Seven Hour
Energy baby you're looking at him I'm
just kidding I came out with seven hours
[__] it's just crashes no they do have
different hours did you win yeah yeah
that was it Charles Georgia I would
assume that's it for Chrome that was a
tough night in the office
once I get home the phone
like man Rogan is looking lean bro yeah
he's paying you that ass is popping
Daddy
you know he's sweating
it's hot in there dude like the lights
are hot
he's a sweaty human in general
he takes steroids and he's open about it
uh he takes trt tests
yeah so let's say you went to the doctor
and they found out you were deficient in
vitamin C like you need way more vitamin
C because you're deficient if you go get
your testosterone checked and they say
Hey you you're you know you don't your
testosterone levels are super low when
you get that back up they're gonna put
you on testosterone replacement so it's
only going to get you to the Natural
levels of whatever age you are let's say
when you're 35 you need to get you a
normal 35 year old's testosterone levels
so how do you get a normal one without
doing that can't you just eat healthy
and work out or is that like impossible
some people can't so there's different
things so if you like grew up playing
sports and let's say you played football
all through high school and you had some
CT CT can cause low testoster what's CT
CT is um brain trauma concussions we've
got a lot of concussions you can lower
your testosterone No Sleep lows your
testosterone [__] being a [__] slows
your testosterone that's too [__] voting
for biting losers I'm good on that one
yeah
but um yeah there's certain things so
people assume like oh he's using
steroids not throwing a new steroids he
doesn't use like deck or winch draw like
he uses trt testosterone replacement
that guy in the front oh you know who I
saw last night chin at uh the one
Championship is
um
Rose was cornering the girl fighting uh
stamp fair tax oh nice dude
stamps so freaking awesome dude dude
hurts dude bro Superstar yeah yeah when
she came out the crowd went nuts dude
yeah and she's dancing and I was like
she better get serious here who are you
talking about this this little girl name
she looks like an anime girl she's like
dancing doing all this cool like walkout
music and then when she hits the
freaking when she hits that uh cage dude
Savage she she kicked this girl in the
liver broke her ribs dude
Johnny Walker it's a tough fight for
Johnny she looks like AI put together
like a super UFC woman
oh Savage dude and then the way uh uh I
think that was a kick right here
think
that was the kick it was brutal you
heard can we can we watch it or no
oh well we can't put on air right now he
could put it on for you but does this go
on the the televised part
uh no it won't you could do it without
sound the kick is Savage and the her
technique is natsos
and then did you see Rod Tang chin
yes how dude so he fought this Mexican
my girl's going for the Mexican I'm like
you're so far out of your league right
now rooting for this magazine so she's
going for this Mexican there he is the
goats in the town
you send out the bat signal what's up
what's up
hey dude nice to meet you man all I did
is put out a bat signal in the shape of
a goat and look who showed up
you want Dom to sit here yeah sure
you need anything done
no good that was the drive not too bad
it can be a little brutal from San Diego
it was traffic I'll be honest I was
catastrophizing
um before I
first I had to solve the problems yeah
and then you catastrophize the trip yeah
okay what's the traffic going to be yeah
yeah but you know we made it work do you
know George have you guys ever met yes I
know George from fine
dating
I'm sorry yeah no I'm with you the vine
was before I became obviously Instagram
so yeah yeah so that's where I know I've
seen you but I don't know we were saying
before he came I'm like there couldn't
be a better guy to have on tonight's
show with the 135 KS going on and then
last night I was at one Championship uh
in a watching Mighty Mouse in Marias
which did you did you watch it at all
um I actually didn't get
to you know it's funny you say that it
couldn't have been a better guy because
you know I'm obviously torn in the soul
watching these fights I know
um it's you're in a weird space when
you're me yeah you want to be doing it
yeah and you're right there and you know
so
the best thing I can do is keep
neutrality and sometimes just shut the
[__] up
I've been doing that yeah well yeah and
then you called me and I got this
should I do this like do I want to do
that oh come on dude yeah I was like
come on send out that goat bat signal
dude
yep uh Mighty Mouse last night so I was
there in person so the whole card was
not so it's like finish finish Mikey
mushumeshi did his thing submitted the
dude the the Coleman event ridiculous
with Rod Tang like he had a crazy
knockout that's Mighty Mouse Marias and
you watch the fight you know Mighty
Mouse 36 Marathi I think it's 34-35 and
I think for the first time could have
been the game plan but it looked like
like he was third like he slowed down a
little bit like you so you know you kind
of looked looked at a little bit of his
age could have been the game plan too
like a lot of clinch tons of clinching
and Mighty Mouse like I think I'm the
best in the world in the clinch that was
the game plan so I get that and he did
beat him up in the clinch but it made
for kind of a boring main event but he
got the job done it's I saw that he
landed the jump knee he landed that jump
knee and that's uh obviously an opening
that he saw from the first one yep or
the second match second yeah because he
landed that same knee yep
um
what's funny is when you watch me fight
DJ I beat him in the clinch yeah so he
is the best in the clinch but when we're
talking about two different types of
clinch right like
Maurice has the frame
but it can't be a Muay Thai clinch
that's what DJ's really good at yeah but
if you force him into Greco clinch uh
you you lift the shorter man off the
ground it's just and that's what you did
with him that was the game plan yeah the
plan was to stretch the little that
makes sense out so we didn't have the
leverage because he has to come forward
yes because with Mariah it was weird
because when he was engaged in the
Clinton rice is huge dude like it looks
like a mismo he's huge he's so big this
guy's [__] huge dude for 35. he's so
big yeah he's so big so I was like oh
Mariah's gonna dominate him the Clincher
he he held him against the cage a little
bit but Mighty Mouse definitely Landing
better elbows better knees and then
after the fight kept going on he played
a little more pressure I think altitude
had a lot to do with it because Mariah's
Roundup to rounds are kind of slowing
down more than Mighty Mouse but that's
always been his Pace though yeah
honestly yeah yeah I know it's always
kept that pace that he counts on out
outlasting most people I was surprised
you were around to do this because I'm
always like how he's working for sure
yeah I was working I got this weekend
off everything was
all good chilling chilling I'm like okay
I'm so glad you did it man I can't thank
you enough here we are I can't think
what was it gonna do sit at home stare
at my dog yeah you know yeah and just
make a trip make some workouts would you
have watched him if uh if you didn't
have to work this gig are you one of
those guys that watch every fight I
watch
I'll be honest like I told you I've been
trying to stay neutral and keep my mouth
shut so I don't know if I'd watch this
tonight honestly I probably would have
been running yeah yeah that makes sense
yeah just kind of like that's why you're
that's why you sound great well I don't
say it to like sound no
it's more like shut the brain off yeah
like that's how I shut the brain yeah
because there's a lot you're just
running like you can't there's you can
only be present and that's really nice
so don fought sahuto who's fighting the
main event Don fatsuhuto so hudu has
been off three years he left uh with the
belt he's coming back fighting Al
Jermaine Sterling
um and it's hard because I didn't
I didn't get a I can't even really like
talk about my fight with him because we
probably went one and one and then the
fight stopped with the second left in
the second round and you were pissed yes
I think it was a really stoppage myself
shouldn't have been stopped but it did
so it's a loss right I shouldn't have
put myself in that situation but there's
a lot of uh different things so yes
responsibly shouldn't have eaten the
shot
um on the other end of things it's hard
you know I didn't get a real read on
that fight or him because right when the
fight started cooking
you know it was over
you you have uh that's one in one I
think you have a tough give gig because
it's like it's a blessing and curse
because obviously you're one of the best
to ever do it at 35 there's I mean the
conversation with Grace 135 or ever then
also you're a damn good analyst so it's
like you can do this for the rest of
your life but then I know you still want
to compete so it's like if you weren't
so damn good at breaking down fights and
analyzing fights I think you know you
wouldn't have this issue it would be
easier I think my favorite favorite
thing is that people are still even like
you're saying like are still separating
it when I'm one of the only athletes on
Earth at the highest level of sport to
do both at the same time a decade yeah
it hasn't been one year I've done this
this hasn't been a month I've been
analyzing fights for 11 years while I
compete at the highest level and nobody
talks about that nuts I mean nobody does
that so I'm just I'm saying like I'm
working three jobs while I compete
against these guys and then let's not
forget that a guy like sahul though
which is the fighter that he is but
I see it a little different like
he rested like let's say we got a group
of of 10 guys and we're all in the gym
training
and we're all at the highest level
he left the room to get a rest yes well
we all kept working yeah and then he
came back he what two years later with
nothing no injury there's no reason to
leave yeah it was just I'm just gonna
leave because I'm the best because
you're the best and he wanted more money
I guess I don't know he cares the bottom
line you stepped out while we kept
working yeah and then you come back
after we're a little bit wore out and
tired yeah like I fought three fights
yeah uh yeah and you're gonna come back
you had no reason to leave yeah and so
the way I see it is you left the
competition pool to relieve yourself of
Duty like it was too much for you yeah
the pressure so
in layman's term [__] move definitely
busy
like I don't respect that as a
championship mindset I mean bro you're
doing three jobs I respect him as a
champion but I don't like that dude keep
fighting
like keep fighting especially at his age
yeah yeah and he's fighting who today Al
Jermaine Sterling so I think that my
issue with that well I think Sterling's
gonna win in my notes why'd you leave
though my thing is that that's all like
you're the best okay yeah
so much for three years was there
anything personal maybe yeah maybe
something family I mean it doesn't
matter I'm out for three and a half
years because I blew my knees out three
times and then I come back and win a
title he's out because I feel like
taking a break and grabbing ass on the
outside of the Octagon so you're saying
you should let go of your belt if you're
gonna do that he did he did oh so then
you're just say it's a [__] move for
leaving got you oh especially so you're
just resting while everybody else works
and you're like okay you know what I
breasted I've been out of the testing
pool so I'm completely rested I've had
no Sada knocking on my door for three
years I've had no call outs I can say
whatever I want I can talk as much trash
as I want you can take steroids because
I'm not saying he is but I'm saying he
could I don't even want to put that on
the table because that would be
exactly no it's just not the respect
isn't it it's just it would be an
interpretation and I don't have a fact
but you're saying but he is getting rest
so forget steroids yes just recovery
because the camps and the trainings kill
you yeah but is that could that be a
loophole though if people take a break
I don't know well I mean it's an
interpretation he still works with UC so
I'll say there's guys like
Conor gets heat right now because he
left and was like on a yacht and yusata
can get a hold of him a hold of him he
had a broken leg and then we see picture
of him on this yacht jacked and you're
like well what's going on here yeah and
then Darren Till's been very honest he
laughed UFC didn't tell him he laughed
he goes I'm leaving get out of usada so
I can do the necessary PDS to get my
knee or leg as good as it can be before
I come back or let's just say forget
let's just hypothetically say they're
not on PDS they're just out you're not
you don't have to have people going I
want to fight him there's no pressure
anymore the boogeyman's gone there's no
usada
and you're just the man like I'm the
Champion I'm retired nobody's gonna no
if I want to say you all suck you could
never compare to me I can say that why
because there's no way to fight there's
no repercussions there's nothing there's
no way to pay but so he's been doing
this for three years on the outside just
staying relevant like it because he's
talking about it gets in the in the news
feed so he he talked about like
volkanovsky right or me yeah and you
yeah so like
he was on the show and I'm like dude how
about him he keeps calling me out and he
goes I won't even mention this I'm not
even going to entertainment he's not
even in the testing pool so he can't
fight for six months so that's the next
two months he calls me out I want to
entertain him you're getting my point as
a fighter it's different you're like why
are we talking about this idiot it's not
even an option you can't you can't even
talk to him for six months before it's
even a conversation correct and so why
are you bringing him up to me when he's
one retired two he's not in the testing
pool which I'm not alleging anything I'm
saying you're recovering forget anything
else you are recovering with no pressure
he's not beating down his body like
you're not beating anybody you're not
beating anything up so it's like the
rest of us are working and then you come
back after we work for two years three
years and you had no reason to leave and
you go okay now that you guys are
working and tired and done a great job
promoting I'm going to come back and
I'm going to treat your rewards
basically I don't know and what's what's
weird too is he loses now though what
happens
nothing it's just a that's my point
there's not a lot lost there's not
there's a lot gained there's nothing to
lose here's the narrative if he wants to
lose if he loses out it's gonna out the
hate on algebra and Sterling he doesn't
get his due so if he loses then you know
Al Jermaine beat up an old guy's mouth
three years even if it's a really
good-handed Studio people go ah al
Jermaine just be able to always
and on top of that see you're getting
you're getting the the excuses that are
set in from that and that's why you
shouldn't get to leave and come back
like this I'm surprised they even make
that out loud unless you're like like
seriously injured
that's my point I never left the pool I
had the most catastrophic injuries of
the history of the sport and I stayed in
the pool and had people calling me out
while I was injured trying to rehab my
knee my knee was like you did it twice
right three times and plus the shoulders
you can't come back and I fought him
after the shoulder reconstruction so the
bottom line is I stayed in the pool this
whole thing so the comparison I'm making
isn't that he's not a good fighter isn't
not that he's one of the greatest I'm
not saying that
and I'm not also not saying that he's
been using I'm saying he rested and got
a break while the rest of us did not and
that is weak to me yeah stay in the pool
yeah you're young you're a grinder you
say you're all these awesome badass
things then stay in the pool with us and
let us test you bro but you didn't let
us test you jumped out of the pool so
nobody could test you so to me and the
pressure's off when he comes back now to
his point the pressure's off because I'm
like yes who's out three years he's
holding then you jump straight to the
front of the line you didn't have to
face any of the Savages like I thought I
chose to fight on Fight Pass prelims
because this is the the task you go to
the bottom of the line and you work your
way back up when you're a champion I've
done that twice I was ready to do that
three times
I had a shot with him different dude I
had a shot with him known with Henry and
I used it during covid
and
on six weeks notice after shoulder
surgery he was preparing for Jose Aldo
and I was
obviously not I was recovering from
shoulder surgery but I pushed for that
fight because I knew if the borders
closed I could get it you don't say no
to a title shot so I got my third chance
he's exercising his
I see the fairness there
just saying I didn't rest do you think I
know you don't yeah I'm with you he
rested when you break it down Jesus and
also do you you don't believe in uh ring
Russ but for Judo being out three years
I think it's going to help him you think
it's because of the rest I swear to God
it's going to help him I really believe
that this is now think about this how
many fights has has aljo had this year
and last year between this year and last
year and how many minutes of fighting
was that he's been pretty active he's
been acting super bring that up Jen I'll
just had a good because he had the P the
two Peter John fights he had the Corey
sander Hagen he had the TJ Dillashaw
right and I think all that well Henry's
on the outside talking trash with no
Sada and no pressure
he's just chilling he's getting fat when
Henry returns Pedro Munoz Corey
sandhagen two Peter yons and a TJ
Dillashaw think about that lineup and
this dude and now what's Henry doing
he's like this
not putting miles on the car chilling
like whatever like cool I get it but I
don't respect it yeah I get it it's I'm
not saying you're not great you're
saying I don't respect if that yeah
aljo's the [__] man I agree he's
taking the chance for this I don't know
I don't get the hate on aljo people just
don't even respect now I get the Peter
yon fight and the hiccup there like he
was getting his ass whooped and then you
know the league I look at it from the
outside like I'm saying from a thousand
yards I'm not looking at just this one
thing I'm looking at like how much look
at that think of this if we go to
basketball or football or any other
Sport and we're betting right tell me
you don't look back at each team's wear
and tear up to that game how many games
did they have how many minutes yeah and
how come we don't do that in fighting
no one ever does yeah how do we not do
that how is that not part of the
conversation until I talk about it
it's never been brought up and it's like
poor Sterling this isn't fair if you
look at it yeah it's not even fair it's
probably going to change but it's going
to change when it's like some people say
though that the three years isn't is not
a benefit see I disagree some people say
it's ring rust I tell you I don't say
that I know I think it depends on the it
depends on the fighter like because he
could still be training that's my point
about the risk he's like but big
difference between training and actually
competing big difference but also
I I did believe in ring rust for a while
I said you got to be active there's ring
rust and then I think it depends on the
guy and then Don Cruz really the first
one when he goes I don't believe Marine
rest that's just not real and I was like
well he's going to learn the hard way
and he comes out and beats the [__] of
the guy after all this [__] and I was
like all right well it's Domin Cruise
I'm gonna listen to that
it takes a certain mindset I think where
ring rust affects certain guys so with
him it doesn't affect him Henry sahudo
you're talking about an outlier mentally
so I I doubt ring rust could be an issue
for him I think it's how okay I think
rust if we're thinking about it it has
to be of how it's being rusted so like
if he's training has a a nutritionist
has a chef treating his life the same
way he was treating it when he was
competing then there is no rust in fact
he's just benefiting because now he's
getting stronger and faster he had all
the rest and then you go okay now I'm
gonna I know I'm gonna fight now so I'm
gonna announce that I'm coming back so
now I have six months yes plus three
months that's nine months
plus the three years not competing so
now I have three years not competing now
wear and tear live my life I'm the man
I'm the best I feel great now I've got
nine nine months before I can compete to
get my body strong to compete every day
to have all the healthy training yeah
he's good like you put the rounds in
yeah after nine months you're not three
three years off yeah you sparred to the
death after nine months any spawn with
DJ you know Mighty Mouse like he's
training Jon Jones like he has some
Killers man Killers where they're at and
the reason he's to be fairy fight ready
has a multi-millionaire owner
oh really yeah
so that's it that's uh his Camp so if
they're a multi-millionaire owner are
they training with the gym or are they
training with Henry um because Harry
don't got multi-million no we've got the
multi-million yeah we train with people
yeah we train with the people that have
the money yeah why are we all at the pi
yeah
are we there for the money or the people
so is Jon Jones there for the money or
the little short guy yep and is or is
Henry so insecure that he's standing on
the shoulders of Jon Jones because Jon
Jones is legit and Henry doesn't feel
legit
and so he has to stand on all these guys
and have all these people talk nice
about him because he doesn't believe it
about himself and stay relevant and stay
relevant that's why I love talking to
that dude Head to Head I'll smash him
head to head talks he has no confidence
but he can fight I love it he can fight
I always say Dom's our version of the
closest version you get to uh Kobe
Bryant he can find the mama mentality
there's a I'll be real Dominator but
don't come fight like but yeah you have
no human like where what who are you bro
you can't even see over this table your
feet are hanging in this chair like
you're a little guy
you're just a little guy bro you're you
poor guy so you gotta have all these
guys talk big about you yeah because you
feel little it's a confidence thing so
how many people are talking big about me
on the outskirts hyping me up do I got
John Jones I got no you just do your job
shut the [__] up
get the job done like fight the person
you either win or you lose or you don't
you don't need all this other [__] Don
if you if he wins this he gets pre I
think they guaranteed sugar Shawn
O'Malley the next title shot I think
it's Genius of of him to say that like I
want O'Malley next that's the thing like
Henry is being smart with the the timing
of everything right yeah like I'll give
him that but
I'm just saying like if we I want to
bring all that up so that people know
it's yeah what's going on look at what
Sterling's doing I respect what Sterling
put in the work he put in the work he
stayed in in the Limelight he stayed in
the threat zone he rematched a guy that
everybody thought he was supposed to
lose to
he hurt his arm went and got surgery and
now he's going to fight Henry after
Henry's been chilling relaxing like to
me
Win Lose or Draw Sterling showed up as a
champion because he stayed in the pool
yeah until Sterling it might be injured
too he was talking about this right no
Sterling was injured he he had to have
surgery his ankle yeah his shoulder and
he had a neck issue previously
um but there's what are your thoughts on
O'Malley
uh well go and take this Dom uh I mean
it's it's just such a big question
as a fighter he looked great he looked
great against Peter Young we just
haven't seen him against the lead level
like marab is gonna be a [__] the
next fight we'll find out next fight
because he beat the number one guy in
the world at the time but Peter Yan
Styles he was a good matchup for him but
the rest of and not sugar I love sugar
you know skilled dude but the rest of
the division or stylistically very tough
for him I'll say this he cut yawn in the
last fight so I do believe he won it I
thought he won that fight yeah I say
that because of the new judging criteria
that they as a as a commentator I got to
go to a judging criteria meeting and
learn like and it was really helpful
like they're scoring a little bit
different they're scoring on damage more
than ever and they're damage is
everything right they're sticking pretty
close to it like bloody nose yeah or cut
or like you know like actual physical
you can see damage they're scoring so
like in that fight
yon didn't make O'Malley bleed and
O'Malley made yawn bleed with the cut
and so they went
it was a really close super close fight
so the one that's bleeding lost because
the criteria people are upset about
trying to get with that yeah but I
agreed with the the decision though I
also get how they could be upset but if
you don't know the criteria yes which I
only know because I went to that meeting
and talked to the refs and the judges so
that was a blessing I got that they
explained that to me that okay and it
also did change my game like when you're
arresting people you need to be looking
for elbows and knees cut them up you
need to cut them you have to cut the guy
now I love the twins so like to me cuts
are worth more than takedowns so Cuts
that's inside that's how I'm looking at
it now yeah because the scorn I wouldn't
right so I'll fake take down to a cut
like how do I fake it take down to a cut
how do I get a takedown to a cut how do
I get them down and cut him that's the
question interesting that I'm that's
where I'm at now because of the
exploring criteria well you have to be
really and is it is it cut easier than a
submission yeah
what about O'Malley as like a like a
superstar for the face of the USA yeah
he is that so he's already done I think
he I think he's massive he's one of the
only Fighters that his his ability to
draw a crowd and his talents are head to
head I I think that yeah well I think
that he got
he was loud enough and willing enough to
put his whole entire life on the camera
that somebody said I've got millions and
millions of dollars I'm willing to air
your house burning down live
nobody wants to see a white picket fence
perfect house they want to see the house
burned down gotcha it's a burning house
and he's willing to show it to everybody
at all times he's very vulnerable he's
the first and he's a hard-ass worker bro
he's a hard worker yes and then he's
willing to put his whole life to the
world like EV his his personal
relationship with his girl like his
partying yeah the open relationship
right the open relationship
it's a younger thing like I think it's
like like uh you know you're young too
but like these young kids like that
fourth wall like they're not afraid to
show that in my day especially before me
very private you didn't you really
didn't dude and I talk about that all
the time Hollywood was so much cooler
back in the day because you didn't
[__] show everything that was
happening and like you thinking about
what a person's doing is way cooler than
knowing every single [__] like you
didn't know every move Sinatra made or
the Rat Pack yeah you just sat there
made it more special and they actually
did something yeah or or when you when
you see them like if you see like an
actual celebrity like back in they're
like holy [__] I saw Robert De Niro yeah
now I see freaking you know whoever
sugar Shawn in his underwear you know
I'm saying it's just they break the
fourth wall which I don't necessarily
think it's a good thing all these guys
are good for the sport and I'm gonna say
that for real like I started the sport
before this like this weight class
didn't exist thank God these guys are
here this is the most air Division I I
think the most com like competitive
division in the world right now and a
lot of it is because these guys have
such cool personalities are you in the
same division as Sean O'Malley or not I
am yeah have you guys fought no no and
you got and Alexa how does that work how
do you fight each other well we're right
there it could it could definitely
happen yeah I'm probably like the best
person to have on this show because I'm
like the Audience
by the way yeah yeah jelly roll jelly
would just hit up the chat he's he's
saying a shout out to you obviously
Brennan and Cruz a man yeah yeah and
George yeah he said shout out yeah I
feel like the third one really didn't
happen
no you're asking all the questions the
shop Cruz and George that's what he said
okay cool no when I when I yeah jelly
texted me how excited he was Don was
coming on when we announced it yeah
jealousy loves you Jelly's the man I'm
the contrast we have a lot of friends in
in similar oh really yeah I've known
jelly for a hot sauce at clay and uh
Scotty Nelson okay run chips and medical
center and TJ Tijuana Mexico okay yeah I
work with yeah anybody who's got any
problems with their body let's get some
stem cells people yeah that's blown up
no but it's good you're here George
because uh a lot of the stuff I just
assumed or saw Breeze past it where
you're it's good but yeah him and sugar
Sean could easily fight yeah that's not
I would love to see that happen now just
because I know you guys now so no
honestly all these fights are right
there and it's it's Iris I respect all
of them I'm the [__] I'm talking about
is like all right he stayed in the pool
let's go you know like we're talking
about
from a thousand yards out how who do I
respect as athletes uh and what you've
done and how you've done it like an idea
is and the Diaz brothers like you know
the gauntlet yeah like The Gauntlet
thing there's an old school group of
Fighters Don fries Drew ficketts those
are the guys I was brought up in the
sport by so when you got a guy who's
running out and resting and then coming
back like that really pisses you off
it's weak man it's like it's like a real
fight club I feel like you've punched a
bag just thinking about him taking
breaks it's just weak like I wanted that
rematch obviously and then he goes and
sits out and then he comes back after I
fight three times question why don't you
just reject them and make it known be
like I'm gonna make an example out of
you you're a [__] I won't fight you I
did I just oh [__] this entire thing
didn't I no I mean if he calls you out
or no you don't want the rematch anymore
he's not gonna call me out but you don't
want the Revenge you should never call
me out bro of course I would take three
match he would never fight but that's
what I'm saying don't you think it would
be smarter for you to reject his request
if he does call you out no he's if he
wins yeah come get it yeah you we hope
he calls Domino's
he won't but you know how many people
are calling out Henry you know how many
people call me out me and O'Malley are
probably the most requested fight in the
entire division because there's some
sort of thing behind us and then we're
perceived to be easy fights probably
because we have lost right so it's like
that's what you look at when you want to
face people how how big is their star
name yeah and are they perceivably
looking beatable or are they looking
like
a freak of nature like people call it I
just think people call out Dom because
you know talking about a goat multiple
Time title holder like because I'm on
this show so now they want to burn you
he's a monster so and then he also got
sugar Shawn who's very famous they think
oh if they have grappling background
like he's probably an easy takedown easy
win he's very famous they'll get a title
shot but nobody's really calling it like
a marab he's not great at marketing
Savage [__] nightmare yeah a good
example is you guys were talking about
um
uh Darius
yeah I heard that he's done the right
way well I was about to say like how did
you hear that well because I was
listening okay amazing bunch of nonsense
[Laughter]
honest on a real note uh Darius just
didn't do the marketing side like I love
how the WWE
has taken this over because you're now
seeing what they actually wanted the
whole time right if you take a if you
take all the WWE why is why has it been
around as long as it has forever still
shows every week twice a week sometimes
massive yeah and it's everybody knows
it's fake and they're still watching it
right that blows me away by the way
that's my point so now we're gonna say
oh well we're gonna make it real now how
many people are going to watch so we're
gonna have the same show that you've all
been watching anyways except instead of
the fake wrestling at the end we're
gonna put a real match a real situation
home run that's actually a home run
they're Geniuses but wait they're doing
that that's what that's what they've
merged they've merged the companies have
merged Endeavor bought WWE so WWE has
the same owners of the UFC now so that's
my point that's my point that's happened
you're seeing what they've wanted this
whole time so if you're not speaking
like the rock with the microphone like
Michael Chandler like Conor McGregor
like grabbing it saying you guys are all
a bunch of idiots I'm
what in WWE do you stand out if you
don't do that you don't have a job you
don't have a job so this is what it's
shaping into so the job of a mixed
martial artist is changing you are now
required to be entertaining not just
fight people be entertainment
I don't think it's good but also if
you've been paying attention for years
you would know that the UFC's model is
based off into McMahon's model that's
who Dana looks up to that's you know
that's his North Star so they're copying
the WWE model
yeah can I ask a stupid question
doesn't this kind of break the backs of
martial arts does any kind of take away
from
things that you guys worked your whole
life to do I see it a little different I
think we still have all the martial arts
is still there they're just teaching us
how to be Showman
how many Marshalls get pushed aside but
that's all of his so this is my question
yeah is Darius getting pushed aside or
is Darius not stepping up to the job but
it's his heart well that's the question
though and it's not wrong or right it's
just the question we all get to be in as
athletes like do I want to do this or
not do I want to stand out I have to
look at what Conor's done and say I've
been in the sport and had more accolades
than him but look at what he did and say
getting more money and you did things
how can I take responsibility for that
because George would be like your boss
company if you were working with company
like hey we want you to do it this way
if you don't you still have a job but
you can get promoted if you do it this
way you're gonna promote it faster and
you go I'm good to go okay but this guy
over here is going to do it that's all
I'm saying it doesn't mean that it
doesn't mean you're not gonna have a job
but you're not gonna be making as much
money as the other so you want the same
opportunity if you want to get up in
three fights talk if you want to get up
in nine fights don't talk just fight
really good it's up to you you better
fight really damn yeah and Darius
fight's really damn good so he's doing
it that's why it's annoying I'm trying
to figure out how is it but for the
Casual fan it's not annoying
oh yeah well look how about this look
right here
are you interested there's no sound no
okay now who could go up there with no
sound and you'd want to see what's
happening that's how I'm starting to
look at it yeah
yeah like how do I make myself something
that people want how do we do that as
athletes so it is you're
you can't just not you can't oh skip
martial arts to be a showman because
then you're really effed so yeah the
martial arts still got to be there but
what's happening is if UFC's going to
expand and be worth more than 4.3
billion dollars they're going to force
us to do what be worth more than expand
got it everybody gets to expand and work
together and grow and so the
transformation has to happen if there's
new Showmanship that needs to be brought
I'm not saying I enjoy it I'm not saying
I'm the first one to act WWE but I do
understand that it's happening again I
like it or not
it's up to you if you want to play the
game or not you don't have to nobody's
making you but then if you don't then
what happens I'll tell you what it is
stressful either way and if you need
some help this show is brought to you by
betterhelp so it's easy to get caught up
in what everyone else needs from you and
never take a moment to think about what
you need for yourself wow but when spend
when you spend all your time giving
thank you sir it can leave us feeling
stretched thin and burned out therapy
can give you the tools to find more
balance in your life so you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind quit talking to your
friends quit talking to your buddies
talk to licensed professionals I'm
talking about licensed Professional
Therapy you can do from your home with
better help so give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief question
or get matched with a licensed therapist
you can switch therapists anytime you
want no additional charge so if this
sounds like something you could use find
more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com shop today you get 10 off
your first month that's better help
help.com
thanks man been doing a hot second you
think though to read like that oh man
it's tough yeah took me I mean many many
years yeah have you ever Hooked on
Phonics I was don't I went to sell
something I went to Sylvan Learning
Center so did I all right for me yes
dude yes give it up and help me at all
because I I didn't know I was a dyslexic
until like like college Years I didn't
even know that was a thing
you know my biggest thing is and Dom
you're great at and John Annex probably
the best Rogan's pretty good at it too
but now the UFC is so International like
some of the Pakistani names the Russian
names
like one Championship was like man
you're interested in doing content I'm
like bro you if you get more American
fighters like I just can't pronounce the
names I just it's not for me I literally
I can't do it I'll tell you the truth
I'm not that good at it I'm gonna be
honest
yeah I'm gonna tell you compared to copy
annik yeah yeah he's really good at it
dude the best he well plus they do give
us like at the highest level like when I
started doing commentary I did it for
shootout Brazil okay and so the whole
card would change the day of this event
like an hour before the event everybody
so you don't have any preparation so
then now you get to the UFC and they're
giving you all these notes and they give
you like they have a guy in your ear
telling you how to say their name right
no way that's my big that's the only
reason why I don't want to see I don't
disrespect somebody but it's awesome I'm
not gonna lie like the the it would help
me out so much yeah the things are there
so I would say to the people who are
worried about you know not having uh
more American fighters get better people
in your ear your producers they're being
silly yeah I struggle with certain
pronouncements producers it's a
nightmare for me
help them out I just use either first
names or their nicknames if it's really
tough I just use their nicknames like
their fight names
find a way around well you got the
paperwork in front of you okay yeah you
have a producer in here there's no way I
would be able to because my nerves would
be too and then it just would all like
scramble oh you're smarter than that
stop it yeah give yourself put up that
thing again let me read it for you let
me see how good it ends up taking the
program because I just can't read it
not when my son struggles with the word
I'm like we need to help right now my
girl's like relax you don't understand I
have like PTSD I'm like no you don't
understand he needs help now I can't
listen to the word popcorn without
cringing because when I was a kid I used
to do this game where you'd read a line
and you popcorn somebody and everybody
would [__] popcorn me because what's
popcorn so you all read a book in class
and you read and when you're done
reading you popcorn somebody so I
popcorn you to pick up so literally go
popcorn you and then you popcorn yeah
popcorn you and you popcorn yeah my [__]
yeah so I'd go to the bathroom and then
just in like yeah as soon as they start
you just find a way out you pull cejudo
take three years off go back and I come
back and they're like you deserve no
respect you don't know what's happening
in this chapters
you get it how many chapters were missed
yeah let's be honest how many chapters
were missed and the new wrestling came
back on chapter six you son of a [__]
the rest of me want to read this stupid
book let's get a cliff notes Dom how do
you feel about knowing your uh kind of
relationship with fighting how do you
feel about morobs and he won't fight
Sterling if he wins he hopes Sterling
goes to a different weight class
he will I think I think I think goes to
volkanovsky yeah yeah that's exactly
what'll happen he'll fight but you would
fight a teammate
I would I would yes I know you would yes
that's what I'm saying I see it
different I see it as a blessing like
you're telling me I get to fight the
only guy I've trained with this whole
time that means we're the two best for
and we're like we did our job that means
we're doing something right we did our
job damn great perspective that's it we
just did our job and now I'm the only
person
that can get you to the next level I
wouldn't want it to be anybody else
great perspective I wouldn't want
anybody else to kill me but my best
friend I feel like you mentally break
people down I feel like you look at such
great perspectives that if you went into
an argument you break them down mentally
thanks I'm just trying to figure out how
do you make what works work you know
like I just wanted to work
you're obviously training because you
came in with a busted lip even in here
yeah I'm training but I have to be work
around things you know I'm you're doing
it man I'm just doing the best I can
with what I got I'm still here and uh
and then how much of a notice does UFC
give you do you know like a year out
what pay-per-views or fight night you're
working because obviously the
international ones Jacksonville oh no
nice 13th
uh that's a big one yeah I think that's
ABC yeah that's a big cover now and I'll
be cool and then uh most of the ones in
Vegas I do because like you said I'm
still training so this is what nobody
knows like why am I not on the big
pay-per-views why am I not on these big
ones with DC well DC's retired yeah you
travel the world and do whatever he
wants I have to train twice a day while
I do this yeah so it's easier for me to
stay at the Apex
train all the way up till Saturday do
all the cramming of watching the film
and do everything I need for the work
but still get my training in so it's
just really beneficial and um to not you
know have to go for a week at a time and
travel and train fly everybody in on
like Monday or Tuesday because it starts
the fires get there on Tuesday and you
do interviews pre-interviews all that
stuff did you do you hate doing
interviews before fights uh you're
saying as a fighter yeah as like is that
the least
chroned it like I know it's like good
for the thing but is it like [__] your
mental state up before so this is what's
so again this is very interesting good
question this is why it's good to have
you man yes good questions it is very
very very frustrating now there's
another step to this of course I could
go with my Victim story right we'll
start with that why are you asking me
these questions that I don't want to
answer that I've been trying to dodge
out of my own brain for three months and
you're gonna bring them up and make me
answer them and now I got to think about
them
and I have like two days till I fight
I've been trying to put these thoughts
out of my head and you're gonna ask me
them you
okay let me answer you
so that's step one that's the victim
story The responsible story is I wanted
to be on platforms I wanted to make a
difference for people I wanted to be
able to make a difference for my family
and be one of the best in the world that
means people are going to look at me and
want to know every single thing of every
single question of every single moment
especially the ones that are the hardest
for me and the hardest ones are the
questions that people are going to ask
when you're about to compete like are
you ready
do you know how annoying that question
is or coming off a loss that's why I
used to hate like yeah you know the last
one was tough like bringing up your last
fight if you lost that too yeah I'm
trying to move on from that dude
talk about that that's a good question
like if you're coming off a loss you
know there's nothing worse and you're
coming off a loss your last fight to
keep bringing it up you know your
striking looked a little and you're just
like oh my god dude do you feel ready
for this one like I hope so see and so
you don't know and that's a victim story
yeah okay it's triggering because yeah
you're triggered but at the same time
it's like you get to ask me these
questions I put myself here
actually this is why martial arts is
here because you're just putting me into
some very introspective questions that
most people on Earth never have to face
let me go smash you and then ask you how
it felt on TV in front of everybody and
other sports don't do it to your point
but also back to your point of uh the
entertainment the entertainment aspect
of it too like that's Entertainment like
yeah but that's why I asked you guys
because you're on the opposite end of it
again you have to do it now there's been
people like Rondo when she she came back
and was fighting man Nunes was like I'm
not doing any interviews and I went red
flag
that's my point like your job is that or
it's or you say it's not right that's oh
so you have the chance to say no I don't
know you don't unless you're on a Rousey
or Connor because you better be bringing
out your eyes whether you talk or not
there is a realness to that again as a
fighter I get to take responsibility for
that am I that fighter am I the one that
has two interviews like you got to be
real with yourself you have to humble
yourself I mean you don't have to humble
yourself but you got to be real people
won't humble but that's why that's why
the viewers brothers are so big is there
any interview that crosses a line and
you're like that guy needs to go bro
like he's I once had a guy I forget he
was a British dude and he goes you're
Underdog in this fight and I bet against
you how do you feel about them like oh
wow fights tomorrow dude I ended up
being the guys that Matt material fine
enough do you ever want to fight these
guys like I feel he's telling you right
now oh you fought the interview you guys
telling you how he felt no I'm just
saying I was like Jesus Christ man he's
like you know your big Underdog man I
did bet against you how do you feel
about you know the oddsmakers on this
I'm like I don't pay attention to that
man now now you bring it up now you
gotta think about it so that makes you
kind of feel a certain way towards that
person yes yeah you've resentment why
would you ask me that yeah
do you but they don't do it to other
athletes to that point like you they
don't go to LeBron like man you know
last finals two years ago you missed the
game-winning shot dude well sometimes
they do they're pretty sometimes they're
pretty sometimes guys yeah yeah let's be
honest yeah something depends they burn
them pretty good but they don't give
them two the NBA does a good job putting
like the big stars on stage but like NFL
they they just decline they don't they
don't do the interviews like if Tom
Brady throws a game you know losing
interception Super Bowl he's not on the
stand what if LeBron took three and a
half years off right now three years ago
oh my God what would happen just to
chill because he felt tired yeah yeah
what would everybody else say just
competitors yeah they'd be like dude
that's such a [__] move yeah I'm just
wondering I think it would be different
for LeBron because he's made it vocal
that he wants to stay around until his
son comes so maybe people would just be
like maybe he's just holding off so he
doesn't get injured until the sun comes
guys I think he's done enough to prove
that he's the best right now in the
league
do you think Michael Jordan or like
currently right now he's not the best he
was now he's you know he's doing 25 a
night but jokic is better than him Joel
embiid's better than him
the ads better right now on his team
than him
but his body works better than all of
them
in current time I think Jordan's better
but
are you a Jordan or LeBron definitely
Jordan because I like I'm not
necessarily just about the numbers I'm
about what a champion
uh is in in their being
in their way of being and like he said
about about like Kobe like a mentality
there's a certain mentality that Kobe
and Jordan had that I don't see in
LeBron LeBron's like you don't have that
killer instinct it's just a different
era I can't there's no other way to put
it in the way of being is different like
the way that he whines about stuff is
different than the way that yes Jordan
and Kobe whines about so it's different
level of like
I don't know when LeBron whines it just
sounds whiny to me and when joining Kobe
do it it sounds like that makes sense
I'm with you I also also the debate ends
when you if you look at like when the
game's on the line you you you're out of
your mind if anybody else can take that
shot besides Michael Jordan everybody
knew you take that shot you have to deal
with Michael in the locker room the
coaches knew it everybody knew Jordan
wants that last shot LeBron to pass it
well I would even say that's his take on
it and that's why he likes Jordan better
yeah oh yeah I say just because of like
how they were outside of the game and
who They Carried themselves out as to
make a difference for others like who
they showed up as to me was stronger and
tougher and who I would choose to model
myself after rather than
LeBron I'd be like nah I'm good was
there somebody you married or like
looked up to in the fight world where
you're like I want to be like him before
you became in your own like these are
great questions because you know what's
funny is because you don't know Dom's
background is so many guys are look up
the Dom and took his style like TJ
Dillashaw
um Cody garbrandt like his his style
movement we've never seen the game
before he changed it by the way no from
everybody
those are my boys I hear anybody say
anything nice about me ever off air they
give you they give you your credit but
for good old nice shots yeah off here
they give they give Dom his credit but
this style was the first one I'll be
hyping these dudes yeah yeah his first
he was his style was like you've never
seen anything like the way he moves like
the changing of positions and all that
now it's changed the game now
everybody's kind of doing it so where
did you learn this move like was it just
through practice or like this is through
your spirit
um I was actually working with my coach
the other day and he was doing it with
the team and I was realizing how natural
what he was teaching these guys coming
up was for me and they're learning it
and I don't even have to think about it
anymore I realized over the years I had
certain things that were in me but he
built them up over time one of those
things is rhythm and timing through
Rhythm and um that's what creates
everything if you have good Rhythm and
good then your timing can always be you
can always lead the dance were you a
dancer
uh in fighting yes but in dancing no
it's too lovely I feel like she would
have been like a break dancer like a
street dancer because when you said
Rhythm like that as I understand and I
know it sounds stupid but I did I
nowhere near anybody here's level but
growing up my my parents put me like
Muay Thai in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and it
was easier for me because I just moved I
knew how to move my body a little bit
you're getting my point yeah
Jitsu are grappling there's no rhythm
and a lot of wrestlers and Grapplers
don't have that basketball Rhythm or the
Striking Rhythm so yeah they do and not
always but when you can mix all that
together that's when you got you know
it's tough to do like those guys that I
mentioned do a version of Dom but not
Dom exactly and it's it's gonna be a
tough style to mimic I think whatever
your coaches teaches
why it looks so different is just
because the stance switch but
everybody's switching stance now who do
you guys think is gonna win here
oh it's a good fight a really good fight
I have my garage had issues last fight
so let's see how she responds after that
last fight
I think Jess is annoying
I'm still in Georgia at the one
Championship I just flew back today from
Denver uh what's the one championship in
person but Rose was cornering uh the
girl who fought um uh stamp fair tax
I've seen Rose in a hot second
Pat Berry was also in the corner
I mean of course there's a there's a
really really their girl lost bad got
kick to the body broke her ribs is
brutal
what are we gonna say George there's
this interview that I watched of Mike
Tyson and they asked him something that
really stuck with me and I don't know
why it stuck with me but he said when
you're fighting somebody what do you
watch do you like look at his face and
he goes no I look at their shoulders
because your face doesn't get his face
is not hitting me what is it for you
guys that you're mostly focusing on when
you're fighting the person in front of
you mine was chest I'd watch his chest
because remember and MMA you got to look
at their their hips their feet and their
legs elbows so it's in boxing you can
get away with watching the shoulders you
know dumb uh I'm always leading the
dance to make them react to my movement
so that uh I don't have so you tell them
where to go I'll tell them where to
throw most the time
do you feel like that's the goal that's
the goal I'd listen to Dom on this not
me there's a reason why I tell dick
jokes and he's well the goal is to try
to move and and try to put yourself in
scenarios where there's like 50 50
chance like I know I'm stepping into
danger but I know what the danger is so
I'm ready for it you got it that's the
best way I can put it but also with your
IQ you know when you step in the danger
you know what you think that's what I
mean by knowing what's coming so like
I'll throw an inside kick switch
knowing that they're gonna hit me with
the right hand so I'll have my hand up
to now now I'm inside now I can land
what I need to or set up an angle so
it's really about like
you don't want to be waiting for
somebody
because then you're waiting to get hit
you also probably losing the fight I try
to be first oh see she was chasing
that's what happens when you chase oh no
I lost a young girl has power too
that was in my notes I thought she
didn't have power so that's why my
coaches always tell you to head off and
not follow that's an example of why you
don't follow like a fighter because did
they stop that too early because she'd
have defended herself or not that was
pretty that was no that was a pretty
good stop but she's jacked that's pretty
good stuff let's show it again yeah
you'll see it
my nose was like don't think her hits
has power and literally just bounces I
mean I think these next fights those two
girls have more power than anybody in
the whole division those two that's both
powerhouses he says You Now power yeah
so this is the reason why nobody should
listen to my notes
look at this see she's chasing her very
verdum steve-ish yeah but see how she's
going in a circle
yeah it's a hook that she did that's how
you know it's not straight back also
George her momentum's coming in so it
makes it worse yeah why did she throw
the same move three times in a row oh
and she had her head in the back very
similar to uh verdum Stipe
oh
yeah I saw her head bounce yeah on the
on the canvas yeah
I'll tell you what the best knockout
you'll see this weekend who knows what's
gonna happen the co-main event Main
Event best not yet you see is Rod Tank's
knockout over that Mexican Muay Thai
Champion that Edgar to Bears so every
time you'd love this Dom so you know uh
Rod tanks yeah he's like whatever 400
[__] fights filthy smaller giant legs
so every time rotating would would get
close
um and he would he would throw a kick
and kind of turn the guy would fire back
with a spinning elbow and it was close
and I was like man rotting has been in
trouble with this so rotten knew he's
gonna do that does the kick known that's
coming as he's throwing the spin elbow
he catches it elbow boom not something
awesome dude when did this happen last
night he catches it he says dude and
they say rotten was on a happy hippo
Kratom let me tell you something about
Rod tank and cradle man listen you guys
know I love my Kratom I use it without
doing stand up I imagine that this
fantastic and there's only one crate of
my trust that's Happy Hippo all right
and they have whatever you need have
powders gummies I use the the shots I
used one right before
yeah dude watch out guys it's addicting
I know trust me and I'm addictive
personality I love it man watch out
people yeah there it is right there see
how the labels all snarled up because I
was chewing on that bad boy
um I love it man it's the only Kratom
that I trust that's Happy hippo.com
thick 23 get 20 for Life share with your
friends happyhippo.com promo code sick
23.
but yeah right things knocked out
nonetheless was amazing it goes right
back into yeah I'm gonna go to the
restroom did you guys want me to grab
you any pizza on the way back I'm good
man I think Dom eats Pizza dude thank
you stop how dare you always have pizza
though okay I'll be right back
and I'm gonna be listening the whole
time so if you guys gossip you can go
live on your phone so you don't miss
anything we just talk [__] about you
when you leave you're like what the [__]
you are waiting he got way nicer when I
got
[Laughter]
this is dude I was thinking how long
you've been doing counting because you
and I were doing it at Fox back in the
day and then computer high level yeah
dude and so that's what like so I've
been doing this 11 years and you guys
are like oh well so are you retired like
I've been doing this the whole time yeah
and if it's up to you you'll fight how
many more times you think I don't know
you know have you ever thought about it
that's a weird question right it is I
always ask when people ask me that I go
are you going to live till tomorrow and
how do you know Demetrius Johnson had
the best answer for it because this
narrative came out as you retire and I I
read the transcript where people say
he's going to retire I'm like I don't
see that out of him and so I asked DJ
hey man people saying you retire after
this fight win lose withdrawal you
retiring he's like I never said that he
goes you know how it is dude when he
fought like you're in the middle of camp
and he's like in the level I'm at I'm
like this might be the last one I see my
kids I'll hang with my wife more he goes
I don't know man he goes I don't I don't
have an answer for it he's like at the
time I felt like that so I just said
have you thought about retirement he
said of course I've thought about it
yeah you think about it you have you'd
be stupid not to like you have other
life that comes in but you also
uh yeah it's part of who like our way we
live this life if I like we just got
made a living doing it but I would live
this life whether I got rich doing it or
not when you started people weren't
making tons
I paid money to fight my first three
fights
like 150 my Medicals were 350. I walked
out with a 50 check Jesus and I fought
in front of 5 000 people wow so I won't
say his organization they were killing
it that guy so the king of the kids I
didn't know this is how I looked at it
back then because it was illegal in
every state oh every state it was
illegal so you're fighting on Indian
reservations first of all so I'm like
man I'm lucky that I'm not getting
arrested this is a win because I'm gonna
do this either way yeah so I get 50
bucks
I'm not going to jail
good to go so it always was fine with me
but you know after a while you start
getting to a point where you got to get
paid and the sports just evolved so fast
oh man once it got to Fox it blew up big
time most of my career was in the wec
before that yeah that's right yeah I was
in that's where you be DJ that's where I
beat DJ that's where I beat Uriah that's
I defended title three times there
your eye is a busy cat because I saw him
last night because he was corner and
Sage Northcutt who got a win yep dude
and they sat me next to Sage's oh I love
her and their Skyler asked him behind
they sat me next to Sage's family
there's my guy
Partners really yes
she's from Tucson Arizona so I got a
crazy Don fry story for you so I showed
up I'm 19 years old and Don Fry's the
man at this time right
and I show up to practice
and he's there and I'm like 19. I assume
Don fry back then he's in Pride yeah
he's still in Pride yeah and so he's
jacked he was so jacked and I'll never
forget like I was like okay I'm gonna
learn from Don pry and he's like okay
you know we're gonna Spar and I'm like
like
he's serious you're huge he's huge but
you're not gonna question the guy no
first of all he's fought with no gloves
yes you know what I mean so he's the
whole
people don't know it's not a sport wined
on Friday thought it is not a sport this
is not like oh like weight classes
didn't exist gloves weren't there like
it didn't matter so when he tells you
gear up I'm fighting you today you're
like [__] I guess I'm fighting Don fry
today so I gear up bring up Don Frye for
George entertaining type in Pride this
is when I got scared this was the first
reality check for me remember I haven't
I've only got
three amateur fights at 155 or three Pro
fights at 155 okay but
he gets in he goes gear up and I go to
gear up and I'm putting my wraps on and
I'm watching him
so he would look like that dude he's so
scary he's so mean yeah let's [__] you
up and then go shoot porn he's scary
yeah he goes shoe porn while he [__]
yeah I mean but he uh it was like
steroid Freddie Mercury dude he
literally goes into his bag grabs two
Vicodin and just chews them but before
we Spar and I'm like
is that what I'm gonna look like if I
keep going down this road like is this
where I'm going I'm like I would never
do that and I'm like I don't know
Vikings are pretty cool I guess
so he like kind of had me thinking about
it I was like is this what I'm supposed
to be doing before practice like this
guy's the best you know and uh long
story short he couldn't hit me through a
head kick and I'm like we just moving
like a man that's supposed to be boxing
yeah
boxing yeah and I was like I'm like dude
you're already bigger than me
you gotta be ready like you just
and I was just like it was the most
nonsense we did two three minute rounds
and you didn't get touched and I made
sure and ran for myself yeah and I hit
him in the body and it did nothing to
him yeah and he did nothing to him glad
you did but it was cool to get to do it
and say that he's the man and that was
my Dawn fry story and I still talked to
him today good dude
good dude you know he's about as good as
anybody from that era
what a great answer
I don't either it's anything else
yeah dude that fantastic see ya
it's doing better than most people from
that area you know what I'm saying yeah
you see here yeah he's there yeah yeah
he's at the event he can see
[Laughter]
you got any uh take on this Gilbert
Burns uh Muhammad fight love it
absolutely love it I love it because
again this is another example of two
guys that I respect yes because of how
they've taken the game Darius respect
that you guys go through the lineup man
they lose and they keep winning they
come back and keep winning and they and
they're facing animals and they never go
I need a break I need to step out and
stay safe from the competition they just
keep going like Win Lose or Draw these
guys neither of them lose to me I agree
for me that's just how active Gilbert's
been too well all too yeah yeah I know
that's what I mean and so I see it as
well I'm coming off Ramadan too yeah do
you think the winner of this fight is
the person who can obviously dictate
forward pressure because they both come
forward I think it goes the decision I
like uh if I was getting a better I like
uh belongs the underdog he's a slight
Underdog plus 130. if he's the underdog
for me he's any either the two are The
Underdogs yep same with Henry and algae
I agree yeah
I know you guys are dying for my notes
so I'll just repeat them yeah tell us
who you got I think I think Gilbert wins
it's a good guess I think I think he
wins
he out boxes him which which punch does
he like right his best punch right hand
what's what's Gilbert's best punch
though if you had to guess one punch
that's his best very shorter fighter
maybe he comes up from underneath and
uppercuts him
with what
one of his hands
stay with an uppercut
[Laughter]
he's hooked by his best weapon yes
that's what I say on the money
Gilbert that's what he has the power so
if it ends on the feet it's probably
gonna be Gilbert what's sorry finish no
go ahead I was gonna say what's cool
about him is that it's not a right hand
yeah he would think it would be your
right hand because he's such a good rest
like he can shoot and his takedown's
like high but he's super good at sitting
up tall and Landing that hook I don't
know what it is that's his punch he's
landed on hamzat like that was a he's a
Savage man what's interesting he lost
that homsat fight but to your point he
didn't lose any
momentum because that was such a war so
good oh my god well that's why this
fight's happening let's be honest the
winner of this fight gets the next shot
I think after after Colby though Kobe's
guaranteed the title shot that's so
funny isn't that weird not weird it goes
right back to what we were talking about
doesn't it yeah so I time and time again
you can see enough of the consistency
that I don't get mad anymore I just you
see the attention I don't get surprised
either I'm like yeah just stop getting
mad and just go okay you'll be getting
something I didn't do yep what am I
supposed to do I gotta be
both these guys deserve like they don't
they shouldn't need to do this fight
they deserve a Top Shot right now but
like if we go back before Dom came Colby
Compton is a guy who's talks that [__]
and people want to see him fight so even
though his last win was against mosville
on him he's taking some time off had an
altercation against Jorge mazdal he's
had a lot of time off Dana was like he's
guaranteed the next house shot and
everybody else that is viewing it
as a sport like other sports like that
doesn't make sense give to Mohammed
Gilbert winner Dana's like no Kobe's
getting the next shot but again to Dom's
point if you know the the sport
uh Kobe Leon Edwards sells way more
tickets and pay-per-views than any of
these guys fighting Leon Edwards the
question is could they say that
I wouldn't if I was them well that's my
point I'm saying it because I can
recognize at a certain point you've got
to be able to recognize like uh all
right I either need to completely shift
homecoming about this or just keep
fighting and winning and that's all I
got here's a question for you though Dom
even though Dana said Kobe is the next
shot no matter what let's say Muhammad
goes out there and starches him in 15
seconds and then rips a ridiculous promo
towards Leon Edwards I think it'd be
tough for Dana not to go all right all
right Mohammed you did enough but you
just said exactly what we're saying I
know favorite numbers no not just that
but like he now you he's playing the
game he's playing he's back in the game
you just played the game yeah so like
yeah Ready Player one yeah play the game
or you don't now the next step is why
don't we want to play the game
that's the real question now I look at
it different what's your answer I'll
tell you my I think for some guys like
uh dear use is just not in their nature
even though they know they could get
further doing that like I'd rather not
even fight for wow why is it not in
their nature to play the game
that's that's what I this is where we
gotta go is it cringy for them is you
know what I'm saying like it just
doesn't maybe why else why why why do
certain fighter why are certain Fighters
trying to play the game and certain
Fighters aren't now we're getting to the
real thing that people don't want to
talk about as Fighters oh you think they
don't want to get caught not backing up
well let's be honest if I go
and I just got here
how much pressure did I just put on
myself
versus you'll see I respect everybody
's really good
respect respect respects he gives me
I'll fight whoever they give me I'm not
gonna call anybody out this week so it's
like one has pressure and one is like
one's a safe route
I think it's per individual I think
there's some people religiously they
just won't they don't want whatever it
is
let's say the Bible doesn't say anything
about that yeah let's say whatever it is
you're making it up
what are you making up that you can't
play the game that's the question I'm
asking what are you what's going on in
your personal life separate from
fighting that you can't play the game
that's a great point so do you play the
game or do you not want to play the game
I choose to not play the game and guess
what I choose to have to fight on fight
past prelims
okay what the [__] get over it
stop whining like just fight like what
are you gonna do one or the other like
or or I'm gonna go yes I'm Jesus Christ
in the making and now but you will call
a guy out though I have you won't back
down I have yeah but it's like
I'll play the game technically I guess
I'd be playing the game now right but
I'm just saying how it is I'm not really
playing a game so that's always what
I've been yeah instead of being more
real I just keep it real yeah you like
me you don't you do if you like me cool
thank you I love you I'm with you too if
you don't
I love you I'm with you too but I can't
do much about you anyways yep you're
there's nothing I'm gonna do I surrender
to that fact yeah uh and you're not
gonna like me whether I try or not so
I'm just here yep
doing the best I can with what I got you
know what I think I think if they're
really bad at like talking [__] I think
it'd be great to hire a comedian or like
somebody that knows how you're getting
into the next piece this is where I give
Henry
uh go to he's done that because he
doesn't like he's not very good at it he
goes you know what I'm such a little
weirdo I'll just stay weird and call
myself cringy and then I can just be me
it's an out because I'm actually that he
eminem'd himself yes and then you bring
all the little people like Jon Jones and
all these guys that I trained and this
Captain America idiot that writes checks
that his mouth can't cash like and he'll
just all these guys will talk him up
about his accolades because he can't say
I'm an Olympic Goldman because you sound
like an idiot you know but he does it
anyways but it doesn't work so he has
these people talk for him and then he
you know you nailed it he hired a crew
and then he just sets himself up I'll be
my I'll just be who I am the moniker of
cringe I'll just be Henry sudo I'm
cringy so I'll just be it but that team
that helps them out that stuff was
talking [__] without Henry was even
talking [__] to Al Jermaine Sterling
like backstage and alja was like what
the [__] are you guys doing man that's
my name oh this is recently yeah aljo's
like I will [__] you guys up this is not
so that's that was my issue too I saw
that Captain America idiot at the pi and
I said yo you've wrote some checks with
your mouth that you can't cash me and
Henry whatever like we fought okay but
you said some things that you're lucky I
don't give you a swirly right now like
straight up you're an idiot and he's
just like oh but I'm not gonna beat his
ass at the pi that's not my job like my
job as a martial artist is even though I
could and I should I won't
I respect that
so just know that little idiot
but there's some guys who don't
subscribe to what dumb song about like
Nate Diaz talk [__] to a man or Jory
Maslow and they see you they're gonna
fight you on site can I tell you
something guys
so much you know what I'm in trouble
though because now that you're talking
about lawsuits well this is what my dad
told me he goes when people stopped
punching other people in the face for
saying stupid [__] a lot of stupid
people started becoming and guess what
the stupid person's still talking so
maybe you got a point that is also still
doing social media nuts right now
there's no repercussions for talking to
people that could absolutely announce
well we just no you just said that
they're doing it to Al Joe in person
yeah and then when that when alge was
like hey what the [__] you doing they
were like oh this isn't we thought you
and he's like I don't subscribe to that
yep so when I come from talk [__] you
know you're punched in the face like
okay we're gonna stop and so Diaz and
then we'll punch you I'll look at you
and say you're lucky I don't because I
have a job and I want to keep it most
you know that's it
simple I got a job I can't just be the
Meathead fighter that wants to smash you
every second especially you have a lot
of jobs bro you can't risk them all no
you're right like did you ever see uh
you know Dustin poorey right yeah of
course 55 Legend Louisiana's finest he
was at a parade in his hometown this guy
had a son that said your wife says your
wife is in my DMs that's a reference of
Conor McGregor after the control yeah
after the fight he goes your wife's in
my DMs
doesn't probably goes like this goes
come here dude and he goes what slaps
the [__] out of him oh no way and he
wanted to jump off the the float and
beat his ass but his his family and
friends were holding him back well did
he get in trouble for slapping that no
no no no no no the cops were yeah what
do you think was gonna happen
but you are lucky if you don't get in
trouble yeah that's what I'm saying most
of the time it doesn't go most of them
you got a loss
just just you guys yeah so Nick Diaz was
in Vegas and someone like tried to punk
yes apparently he's like a recording
artist he tried
apparently Nick Diaz's team somehow hit
his car this recording artist and then
this is what Nick Diaz did
he actually tried to de-escalate the
situation
oh Nick was trying to talk about it
exactly
and everyone thought like dude Nick
could destroy this guy but yeah good
friend well he's probably learned from
his brother right because his brother
had that issue yeah yeah although that
seemed more like self-defense I think
can we watch this when this isn't going
because like my eyes are going back and
forth it's all good we're not gonna show
this he's just de-escaling it he doesn't
hit him or not okay no nothing happened
now you don't want to miss this fight
I do think it goes all five rounds
hopefully I'm wrong I do too but if and
if Muhammad wins it would be my decision
I think he doesn't get a lot of finishes
he's got last finish in his last fight
against Sean Brady but Gilbert Burns
definitely different animal
foreign
X arms
I want to see this fight on the ground
me too
and you would hope Muhammad doesn't
think well Mazda did good job defending
on the ground I can go to the ground
because then I do think he would get
finished
I'll tell you my pick of the night for
prop bets is Al Jermaine uh submission
there's like a plus 550 I'm like man if
he wins price a mission
I think that if like if I like from
watching I give the edge in boxing
to Henry and pressure and I give the
edge in kicking to grappling to aljo
agree and so I go all right which which
can you land first
I also think aljo on your back is
special man that's his that's his sauce
and he figured it out then I gotta think
that's the one thing Henry won't allow
yeah agree he's going to stop that at
all I guarantee you he won't I I almost
you don't think I almost guarantee you
he will I don't think that I think
that's a one thing under all costs that
Henry's it sounds like that's what
they're working on because DJ was
training with him he's like you know the
one thing about alja which makes him a
super outliers his his Bat when he gets
your back who knows that so like they're
they're not dumb like he's got a good
camp so they're gonna have all the
preparation for that backtake the
question is is aljo that special getting
your back where even if they focus on
that a guy like Kenny pseudo can't even
stop it I don't look at it as taken the
back see the I look at it as wrestling
and then he skips a step so instead of
throwing hooks he goes straight to mount
from the takedown so the question isn't
if he can take the back the question is
can he get the takedown that's the
problem yeah he only gets to the back
because he gets the takedown on
everybody yeah when they turn yeah
that's true so now can you or scramble
Maybe
and a scramble that's his best chance
but that's what I see Sterling needs to
do to win and Henry knows that so what's
Henry going to do not let scrambles
happen what's he gonna do create a
stagnant stand up boxing Style Match
yeah that's what I think you're going to
see sprawling brawl he's going to try to
keep it at space
because I do think Henry has the power
Advantage too on the feet well he's just
more comfortable there with the Box the
boxing range yeah and so you can
probably box a little longer
now I think aljo could get up on rounds
just through light kicks if he's
sticking moving land that leg kick
that's his game right so that's what
we're comparing yeah for sure it's a
great fight it is yeah so is this that
was a great takedown offense by Muhammad
Jesus man um what's the number for the
the number four uh wealthy weight in the
world and the other guy's number five
now even though mohammed's number four
he's still Underdog to Burns because
sometimes once you get in the top ten
it's all about stylistic matchups got it
like even though sugar Shawn's number
one in the world Murad might be two if
they fought uh sugar would be an
underdog
Yani uh takes on uh Francis the way he's
been negotiating things oh [__] he heard
him with the jab nice jab it's the
stance which it's killing him it was
actually a left hand and that's what's
hard when a guy's switching as much as
oh he caught him he's bleeding so that
counts for something yeah it definitely
does and that counts for more than not
right we've done but they're both
bleeding right now are they both cut I
think I think just Gilbert knows he's
bleeding off that jab yeah that jab was
nice that's a good note though to know
what's crazy about this stance which is
now you see you think it's a jab but
it's actually a left hand because it
started as jab and you don't see the
stance switch so now it turns to a left
straight and that's more powerful than a
jab so you're hiding it so The Stance
which I started doing that but I wasn't
doing it set I was doing it for little
moments and that's why I look crazy and
back in the day nobody ever did that I
was told it was wrong now you're seeing
paladu's complete stance switch like
he's set in it see how he's going back
and forth I don't I kind of yeah I kind
of set for a second and then go back and
then set these guys actually switched
their defenses there it's really good
like it's hard to do that like the
equivalent would be
a baseball player being able to bat both
sides or a pitcher being able to pitch
both sides right or
quarterback being able to throw both
sides yeah just as well that's what
we're talking about that's what these
Fighters are doing now so great round
for Muhammad man great round definitely
switching it up on them he's got more
tools because the stents which is so
crazy yeah and it's confusing or it it
looks like it's getting a little cloudy
for when it for uh Gilbert when he does
that well it's hard to tell him to take
him down what'd you say do you think
they're going to ask him to start taking
into the ground
because if he's getting out he's just
said than done he had a good shot he was
in pretty tight there and mohammed's
takedown defense is no punk and then the
stance switch makes it that's what I'm
saying like
when the guys are always that nightmare
now you got double reads because when
they're here you're like okay he's
looking for the right kick switch now
you got to reset the whole read and you
have to think about it now he's looking
for what left hand left kick oh switched
again yeah he kicked straight forward
and he was like if he would have leaned
in to anticipate something else he would
have get hit so I'm understanding it a
little by little great round for
Muhammad if you bet on him you're
feeling pretty good right now
Gilbert looks a little flat maybe wakes
up in this round but he looked a little
flat that round
he's just trying to knock out so bad and
he needs to be okay with touching yeah
just like touch touch and then heavy
touch touch touch heavy but Gilbert
wants to hit him with one shot
a little better this round
now does Muhammad fight like this always
does he switch up his stance or did he
do that purposely for this individual
fighter I don't remember doing this much
like with Sean Brady he didn't have to
against John Brady because he's not as
dangerous on the feet
um she's doing it more so than ever this
fight because he's really oh nice right
cop there
um he's improved a lot yes he's like
over the last span of six fights has
just like gotten really better and
better and better each fight so I think
that it's just improved
but he's done it just gotten better and
better at it
the defense is the impressive part to me
when guys switch it's not necessarily
are you throwing it's like are you able
to defend
I would say that's the most critical
thing because a lot of guys switch in
the their defense when they switch from
traditional softball their defense goes
down the drain yeah that's why it
impresses me when guys yes can do it
now you guys talking about burns the
defense or Muhammad Muhammad's when he's
switching stances because we switch to
South Park talking about a different set
of weapons you got to deal with his
defense from South ball traditional well
think of it this way let's say you
you're used to driving on one side of
the road switch it and how's your
driving defense going to be gotcha wow
what a great analogy unbelievable
actually immediately I downloaded what
your mind says
I'm telling you dude you should really
do this I think you can do this
though yep
that's the other thing that goes into it
too George is like let's say Muhammad
wins this it's not an exciting fight but
he wins by decision that goes into if
you're they're going to put you in the
main event if they're gonna put you on
the in the title fight because if
there's a guy let's say Muhammad has
whatever nine wins and they're nine
decisions with one finish
but there's another guy who's 4-0 four
Knockouts under a minute that guy who's
four and I was probably gonna get the
bump
um yeah like when I got my title shot
it's because I won in a minute by
knockout is that why he's trying to just
knock him out and not just no it's just
a stop
all right it's his style but we heard
him on that one but it's like that's
what we need to do to beat the line
almost essentially if you're not the
talker then you got to have some kind of
crazy Alex Pierre yeah exactly that's a
great example he yeah he moved right
through the line knocked everybody out
that's how you do it four or five you
don't have to say one word if you just
knock everybody out you don't have to
sell nothing you can't speak English
really
100 fact
almost made him scarier too oh I agree
and then I just critiqued I said I think
you know that's a weird thing to say I
think I said I think his easiest like
best matchup is Izzy he knows him he's
fine before is he's a straight Striker
The Other Guys in division can grapple
he gets tough for him after this yeah
they hear my show in Brazil it got to
him you start talking [__] about that
fight's got to happen again you think
it's gonna happen again I hope it does
they just I could see that fight
like you know they need to have a
Trilogy in MMA yeah
they've had it outside I guess right I
just I think Izzy would have to go up to
205 for it to happen again because that
looks so big for the weight class
I think he's gonna go to 205 and him at
205 is [__] if Izzy gave him a shot
at 85 he would take it tomorrow
1005. I don't know
yeah because but again when you look at
is it 85 there's not a lot for him
they're talking about they had to go all
the way down to number six
why not just I agree what else you're
gonna do and like that's the best you've
already beat him
everybody's gonna watch it no question
that's a good point no question you're
watching that hell yeah no matter what
oh and for Izzy it's like all right I
guess you're gonna call it duplicities
it's like the number six guy he has to
do some work man
the pier at 205 is [__] scary look at
the matchups there's so many fun
matchups for him yeah and Dana said he
was like we're not giving him Top Shot
right away he needs to fight you know a
contender and then we'll give him a shot
we don't know how he's gonna get to a
five I know Johnny Walker's fighting
Anthony Smith but I love Johnny Walker
pierra
yeah they'll make a good fight yeah
Shelby's nice with that
well and then you got you got uh homslot
coming up to 85. I'm excited to see when
he goes again
I thought they're gonna do him versus uh
Apollo Costa yeah I heard them talking
about it because of the aerial show I'll
be on Ariel's show on Monday too so oh
dope let's do it pretty much said
everything here though
how do you feel about him as an
interviewer Ariel
how do I feel
as far as journalists go it just depends
but
as far as like like legit journalists
he's the best we got I try not to lose
things when it comes to these types of
questions I try to just let it be what
it is because
if I start bringing my feelings into
stuff it doesn't go well
you get too real on them yeah just keep
it neutral everybody's good
if at school he's cool great work Ariel
he just has very good um viral Clips
because I I rate a show on how viral a
clip will go from the show that's what
draws me in to watch the whole thing
because you're watching small bites yeah
I digest it and I'm like oh it's like a
sample like if you go to Costco and they
have like samples if you like it You're
Gonna Want but that's the that's the the
algorithm the business we're in right so
let's say this show would be three hours
right now out of this three hours people
go whatever only got 200 000 views which
not terrible 200 000 views but you got
to realize we'll clip this thing up this
thing through the clips and the whole
thing will get you know five ten million
views we had a clip from last time get
whatever three million views yeah you
know so the games changed a little bit
but it actually made it easier for us as
entertainers because we're like oh we'll
just clip it up and just distribute it
yeah it's just changed you know to Don's
points like with the UFC you gotta talk
that [__] and stay current and you know
make your money in in the game more and
you know it's the clips and
that was respectful
and then there's some guys that don't
need Clips like Rogan you know he's such
a monster and his fan base no no that's
not true there's a lot of clips of his
that like go away no
his his overall podcast like his three
hour podcast that he does is the biggest
thing he does something now there's some
clips that will get big but the Elon
Musk interview or the I think what you
mean you've seen clips of them I just
think that bigger than his whole show no
which is rare which is very real I don't
know I don't know if I could agree
because it's not even but but the thing
about the only place you can watch a
full episode is on Spotify that's why I
say I disagree because I think he's so
like big on Clips on every other
platform even when he was on YouTube his
show was bigger than the clips he's the
only one I've seen that does that his
show was actually the overall three-hour
show was bigger than the clips now
you're talking four years ago the game
changes so fast so fast he's the only
one that knew that was like that I don't
know anybody else now it's all you know
it's clips clips Clip Clips that's what
gave Dana the idea for a slap fight and
it didn't go well
because they dominating the clips and to
his point not a bad business move he's
like man these things are getting
whatever four million views yeah but not
if you're selling tickets that's not
great he we didn't know till he tried it
though yeah you know
that's crazy because that left kick of
Muhammad is with shutting down the right
hand of he says him to throw up he's
fine and then he can't he's not firing
he's left because he's blocking with his
right so it's shut down both his arms
smart
and it's happening from Southpaw like
all the work he's doing for Mom is is
South Paul like he'll land a couple Jabs
conventional but that's not what's
sticking Burns it's that that kick in
that backhand mohammed's just a [__]
dog thing about dude came off Ramadan
you're training some you know and then
you're basically fasting all [__] day
when did it end two weeks ago so he had
two weeks to eat yes
and trying because you can't you know I
mean he said he would train some but he
said he said mentally he goes It Made Me
Stronger he was it was actually a good
time to do it because mentally I was so
strong
he was physically I can get there in two
weeks he was mentally it made me
stronger than ever so it ended April
20th
because I asked him I was like man it's
kind of a it's you know it's gonna hurt
you not being in training yeah quick
hands wow I feel like he's just waiting
around for an opening that he's not
getting but if he does get it Gilbert he
looks for the for the for the big shot
yeah well that's what I'm saying that's
what's that's I mean he can knock him
out but that's what's helping Muhammad
right now it's just looking for one he's
not throwing he's loading a lot yeah and
so instead of like touch touch touch
heavy Dutch mohammad's not playing the
game like comes out played the game he's
like yeah let's fire back and forth in a
phone booth and mohammad's like we're
not doing that I like to look at it like
would you rather get shot by a shotgun
or you know one bullet like you get the
spurt or you get one and like right now
Gilbert's throwing one and you know you
need combinations to hit a guy who's
switching stance and moving all over the
place like Muhammad wouldn't you say you
need those combinations to land that one
eventually right exactly yeah you gotta
touch touch because they're just all
over the place
does it hurt you this might be a stupid
question does it hurt you if you
overthrow does that go against your
score or do they don't they don't care
how much you're thinking it hurts the
fighter as far as stamina wise because
it when you but it doesn't go against
your score right like it's not an
average no okay
which it's going to fatigue you more
yeah of course when you throw punches
and you Wing them yeah when you Wing
them you lose balance which creates
openings yep
man I don't know why I feel like
Gilbert's gonna get one really clean
shot
not not with him I would fight like this
he's calculated I don't know why I just
have it in my gut I could I'm probably
gonna be wrong but I just I feel like
he's it's gonna be out of nowhere too
the beautiful thing is we're wearing
four ounce gloves so yeah it could
happen and see how it happened yeah
come on it was interesting Kamara called
out Hamza he's like that's the fight I
want like that's interesting yeah I love
it I think it's smart
it goes back to your kind of blueprint
you're talking about a true fighter I
like scariest fighting divisions like
holy [__] your balls yeah that's like
win loser draw you did not lose to me
I don't think we're straight for it yeah
no I dig it definitely respect and it's
gonna be fun to watch [__] yeah like
it's not like you're trying to put
together a fight that doesn't make sense
no that also makes sense take my money
yeah it's sick yeah hell yeah I I doubt
the UFC puts that it builds that as a
main event because of hamzat's uh weight
cutting issues to to 170 he's just so
big man have we heard anything from
Comsat at all they can't find him a
fight people keep turning it down
because I was the first one to call him
out and then those then Hamza was saying
like all these fighters to your point
all these fires like yeah they say you
know they offered me Colby they offered
me Paulo Casa he's like this it's not
true like those guys turned it down but
they come out in the media going yeah I
want Hamza he's like they have the
contract why not sign it
to your point two Gilbert's bleeding man
so with the judge and that looks a
little frustrating yes they wonder what
he's saying right now
right here though
um
there's coaches trying to tell him it's
because the kicks by Muhammad are they
alluding to any of that
keeps on the left I think you might be
injured a little bit yeah he heard his
left out I saw his left hand I saw him
wiggle his left hand I think his left
hand's hurt so him Sally keeps wiggling
his left hand that's his best tool huh
yeah it's his hook I don't know it could
be wrong obviously we don't know I can't
even hear what they're saying
I'm surprised you guys don't have
subtitles
can none of us can read bro we already
went over that remember it's my type of
people but all from the Sylvan Learning
Center dude you want to make his room my
mom wasted so much money there poor
woman
help me with math
I just like the toys you could get with
your fake money oh dude I love that that
was so cool and it was right next to the
Guitar Center so I just go and play
drums when I was waiting there's always
some [__] toys though no mine was
lit mine was like toys that I like if
you got like 2 000 points so if you're a
nerd
yeah that's true yeah
oh let's go
oh he's really gone in for it now
yeah and you see um the law is throwing
small shots Jabs you're right he is
going like that he's touching he's just
touching and you see Gilbert's nothing
but Power all two punches as hard as
possible and Gilbert's only throwing
that right hand to your double jab right
hand not hard yeah they're straight
they're light and they're just finding
range and then the big kick lands so you
find them with the little shots and then
land the big one and Gilbert's just
trying to land the big one instead of
finding the little ones first
is do you think it's because he knows
that he's getting out boxed right now to
Just Tire him out so no it's just
because it's the style yeah he knocks
people out and he knows it and so he's
trying to yeah because he's one of those
lands even though he's down three rounds
one of those lands this thing's over
yeah because I sound like I know what's
going on and then he goes what and he
goes see yep I told you look that's why
I do that and it's like yeah you're
right it can go either way that's the
game we played like
that body kick is nice he's been using
it really well to shut down that's shot
Gilbert down that back kick from South
Paul has shut him down really oh there
it is that's a nice guy that was really
nice that's what he needs to keep
throwing though Gilbert needs to keep
doing that I wonder if he just he gets
tired easily so he doesn't do that
that's the stat switch I think how do
you feel about um Conor's stamina
stamina
oh no he's been out we'll see no I'm
just wondering he looked good and that
doesn't pour it if I do broke his leg
like it was he didn't look bad
he always does until he doesn't I feel
like yeah goes south yeah he always
looks really good and you're like oh
it's interesting because the the coach
on Ultimate Fighter but you know he's
not even the testing pool right now so
the same thing with yeah he's calling
everybody out but it's like hey do you
guys know how this game works you know
he can't fight yeah but at least this oh
nice right hand come on the one thing at
least McGregor's putting himself in that
yeah yeah he's in it now right yeah like
you're in it yeah like so now you're
gonna have to eat it one way or another
whereas these other guys are just
sitting out not having to eat nothing
yeah you're just there's no pressure on
it yeah you're just hiding while
everybody else is under pressure working
there's an exemption that UFC can use
there and if they're going to use on
anybody it would be Connor
I've shaken it out yeah I think he's
yeah Dom alluded to that earlier that
and I didn't notice
and if you notice he's only throwing the
right hand and like I said multiple
times yeah so yeah that would yeah now
he's shooting it yeah it's hurt see he
didn't throw it yeah he checked it out
there again he wanted to throw it but
so yeah oh he's like hitting his left
hand yeah he knows it's hurt
probably
yeah a shout out for Muhammad you know
five rounds It's just tough not to give
this guy a title shot but it is what it
is
and he's really beating up his left side
him versus Kobe will be a good fight
though great fight
what do you think right now powerful
pound is like one of the best
well I mean we we know it's Jones right
now
I agree from my experience yeah it just
is
Jones had an interesting comment when
they said you know if you beat Stevia is
that it he was like I mean you know that
Pavlich is there sergey's there he's
like but it makes no sense dangerous
dude no following
so I'm gonna do well on pay-per-views
he's like so I'd probably retire unless
France comes out so that's the sh that's
what I'm talking about yeah like that's
the thing I'm talking about that's not
the fighter you know well it's like
purest so what you choose who like I
don't know like what if nobody chose it
you never deserve anything yeah then you
never would have gotten there yep so
like now you're gonna do that to other
Fighters yeah why it's like fight
somebody don't just leave I'm not saying
you can't say no to people
but don't just leave
yeah or don't say yeah this guy must
he's probably my worst matchup pick
somebody just I don't get how you can
just say no nobody's good enough yep
somebody is yeah at least one
and from all
to fight if if they're not good enough
then just embarrass them and keep making
money yeah or are you scared to take the
risk yeah there's no reward to the race
that's what I'm trying to say that's
that's why people leave that's why
they're retiring that the risk is there
and they're unwilling to take it
poor Gilbert man he's getting beat up
yeah he was left hands down What's
Eating Gilbert boom it's frustrated uh
Muhammad is thank you for laughing at
them
oh well I thought they landed better it
was a good role by Muhammad
one of the coaches staying there
keto George
throw kicks
I'm saying news anything but the left
yeah
yeah he has a tough task man not only
got to beat Muhammad he's tough enough
with two [__] fists and he just got
rid of his best weapon
and Muhammad's Alma man he looks
phenomenal
he's ready look at him
he's a good promo out of him too I bet
I think he mentally checked out because
he can't Gilbert yeah
It's just tough man when you're limited
in you're fighting at this level you
know
especially not only limited but your
best weapon your left hook you can't
let's not this is the last round yes so
he has to do something here it's over
well I know Gilbert never really because
I know I mean another really mentally
checks out but you're looking at the
order you have and you go okay this is
gonna be
it's gonna be a crazy round I gotta kick
and use the same only one hand and he
knows I'm down one hand so it's like all
right let's see if I can get this done
and he's even limited on his grappling
because you can tell like his hand so
injured he can't even really shoot in
properly
again like these are little things that
you're like man you go back and you go
yeah people were watching go Gilbert
wasn't as good as the law and then you
can just go if he loses right but you
can just go yeah but you don't know that
my hand was shattered in the right place
and then nobody knows the backstory and
then they think that you know
you're that much better than the other
guy and it's just crazy how that works
there's so much to this
well how about Izzy posted that video or
someone from Steam post that video of
him tearing his MCL two weeks before the
last period it happened so much to
people to so many of us right and it's
good that they're docking it now well
you can talk about it when you win but
you can't talk about it when you lose no
because that's absolutely okay yeah so
that's why it's interesting to have Ryan
Garcia because I knew he was injured
going to that fight we got hit to the
bottom like
you know if he's not injured now does he
win a fight that's up for different
debate but the reason he stayed down is
because he came in with the you know
injured rib well I mean that's one take
or you could say man if I never been hit
in the body by a southpaw like you're
telling me I wasn't ready for that yeah
like especially knowing my ribs are hurt
yep you prepare for it yeah we he knew
he was going into that fight hurt I knew
I was going into the so but this so did
his opponent though that's the problem
maybe but no no that's what they told
him yeah but we all know things about
each other like it's not really fairly I
don't know it's not really it like you
took the fight so let's say they were
right before the fight they go hey tank
knows your ribs are hurt is he gonna
scrap the fight no no he's gonna be like
I don't care I'm gonna kill you anyways
yeah yeah so it's like a good point
though yeah he always has good points
thank you for being here I'm glad thanks
for asking great questions that's all
I'll be worth right now
yeah that kick has been blasting all
night that left kick
and Gilbert had the right answer to
attacking that inside leg but
it's not breaking it down that's not
enough
props to watch oh over four and a half
five yeah that's an easy bet
I thought that was saying currently
problems but that must have been before
the fight yeah see how he's just
touching yep that's the difference it's
the touches he's not sticking around to
get the because he's not committing yep
it's just touches so you don't have you
can move
and not over commit it's a little risky
though right now I'll try to be on the
well no but he's not risking it because
he's not in and out it's the opposite
he's not sticking around bro if that
would have connected
he has not thrown his left at all
oh
it all stick around Muhammad
holy [__] those advertisements finally
got me the new Spider-Man comes out June
2nd
I [__] love that man my kids are
obsessed with the spider verse those
never work wow now I get it
wait is that a cartoon I don't want a
Modelo or like uh yeah uh spider-verse
yeah it's best Spider-Man of all time I
haven't watched that one yet oh [__]
you're missing out really is it good
yeah all right come on I was watching
you I took my my son was obsessed with
we got the Jordans that he wears in it
we're doing six weekends in a row wow
insane I was so sick with my cartoon
version come on bro it's so well done
though by the third one I was so over it
they're good though huh oh that one's
good whole cartoon series just that one
movie the spider-verse the animation is
nice
yeah he's trying with that right hand
yeah what's the fight and get we're
trying to lure him in again never even
for one second anime no no you're down
you're like all right how am I gonna do
this he's trying to lure me like come on
man let's let's bang and well I was like
absolutely not yeah I'm in a circle
four rounds of work I'm not gonna risk
this
foreign
just keep them keep them off
oh well uh it seems to me that every
person I voted for this time uh lost
that's all right dude
don't be so hard on yourself who's the
underdog in this one Mohammed yeah he
was a slight owner died I picked him as
a dog wow
and the algae is a plus 100 minus 120.
so who is a minus 120 those are close
odds it's basically even money in MMA
uh canelo's fighting tonight he's up
really he's a minus 3 000 I think wow
my good my they're from My Wife and him
are from the same Hometown so you know
she she loves them should I'm buying the
paper I'm like why
this is a [__] minus three thousand
I'll tell you how it goes he wins
he's a minus two thousand so you gotta
Risk 2 100 bucks
so he's just finding somebody for fun
I mean in that weight class like John
Ryder is no punk but it's you know he's
he's the he's the guy he's the next
Contender up so Alfred so if you spend
100 bucks on the other guy you win 2 000
yeah that seems like a pretty good odd
well the other guy's plus one thousand
so you spent a hundred you win a
thousand
that seems like a pretty I would like
just throw that if I was a gambling
people do that I mean I'm a Gambling Man
but I wouldn't do that you're just
throwing money away you think Canelo
canelo's too [__] good
oh wait it's over you have the law got
another one blog another one wow what's
over uh the Canelo fight's over if
that's if Wikipedia is Right
unanimous decision he lost no he won how
dare you
they gotta give it to him now well but
then but here's the thing to to Dom's
point this entire episode he should and
now he's gonna be next in line after
Colby
and Dana's really put his foot down and
was like nah man Kobe's the guy
Joe has such strong opinions and he
doesn't really back down does he ever
bump with the UFC about stuff no because
they're they're in line with him they
have the same opinions hmm
I mean y'all give them [__] over certain
things like he thought
um
like Patty pimlet lost the fight and
said it you know so what he says has a
lot of power too especially if you're a
fighter
what's he saying keto George
this goes back to the entertainment
thing hey man you did good it's like he
carried away here it's uh let's relax
yeah we're selling WWE let's relax
yeah nothing there's no nothing's over
so that's the thing like you're hearing
this who somebody called out Brock
Lesnar recently too like I forget who it
was
I'd like to fight broccoli I'm like you
know what's crazy is uh I could see John
and Brock fighting now especially with
the merger yeah that people would that'd
be if I'd get John out of you know stick
around how old is Brock though come on
uh [__] yes there's no way late 40s
right yeah and then don't forget about
that testing pool we keep talking about
how dare you bring that up
that'd be a pig issue though
you'd be cool everybody yeah it depends
on how they
be cool
how about you want to see Brock fight
he's 45. well Danny can't do much about
that really come on osada like what
that you got to think like the way I see
it is Dana's got to keep cool with the
Sada like he's got to keep cool with the
commission at a certain point yeah like
you because you want your business to
work so you're gonna take us out aside
you're going to take the commission side
and nobody else matters under all costs
because it's the business and I get that
yeah that's it any other investors and
so on so you can't
yeah so the fighters don't really matter
because you can replace us you can't do
anything to the commission yeah nobody's
bigger than anything to usada
man what a great freaking win for
Mohammed
gotta do until shot now after Colby
yeah that was awesome I love when the
camera stays on you for way too fall out
he called out who both Kobe and Leon I
should have picked one
[Music]
let's go
did they already show Frank Yeager in
the background how dare they not give
him camera time no we know why we just
went over all this and you just saw it
live so say what you want or just put on
the jacket it's up to you
or just get back on Fight Pass prelims
and don't wear the jacket
it's up to you
oh we don't have jackets we got new
tiger thick whiskey merch just dropped
tonight on thickboy.com we got whiskey
glasses hoodies teas the tiger thick
merch is available right now on
thickboy.com new fancy glasses we got
the ice cubes we got the maroon hoodies
room T's black tees black hoodies it's
all available right now thick boy.com
get some right before the main event
the prop bets were interesting
they should bad prop bets it was like
Henry cejudo less takedowns in algermane
I don't know who's gonna bet on that
who do you guys have in the next fight
for I don't know I know you're a big fan
of Henry
I don't know for whatever reason I'm
siding with aljo on this for some reason
and I like both guys I you know
oh I can't wait for this but uh I love
both guys you can see both guys winning
but for something in me says aljo gets
it done I don't know how though because
to a Dom's Point his his key to Victor's
submission now could he win via decision
getting the light kick screen distance I
guess
but at some point you know yeah yeah he
has to win by submission or like take
the back yes and control and control
like you did against young like he
pretty much has to be Henry similar to
how he beat Yon
and I was also surprised how he took
yonda
well that's that's what I'm trying to
say like
how did he take the back of yawn it
wasn't taking the back of yahanna was
taking you on down yes how do you take
down Henry so I don't think this fight
has anything to do with except
can aljo
create a grappling scenario and what's
easier is it easier for algo to create a
grappling scenario or is it easier for
sahulo not to it's easier for sahuda
sorry I'd say if I had to choose a
winner that's how I'm looking at yeah
the odds aren't so who does what's
easier to do is it easier to stop a
grappling match or is it easier to
create a grappling and for for I think
for Henry it's easier to stop a
grappling match keep it a boxing match
yeah defend the kids keep the pressure
keep the pressure defend the kicks keep
the pressure defend the kicks box box
box work your way into the pocket and
try to stay on that yeah the whole time
and win a decision and land the bigger
shots and create some damage uh that's
probably how I see Henry doing it if
you're Sterling
wait for Henry to come inside the boxing
range and grapple grab a hold of a leg
pull a half guard go from half guard to
body lock go from body lock crate
scrambles like I see Sterling wanting to
create scrambles and that's where his
openings will will be you know in the
scrambles
you think it goes a decision
uh
yeah that's a good question to deceive
if I had to bet on it I'd say
probably go with
uh TKO
sahuda with hands yeah
I had to guess yeah put my house on it
yeah you said you would if I had to put
yeah
yeah but but if I have to just bet for
the BET Sterling's the best bet okay for
odds and because but it's just like when
we look at it stylistically but I said
the same thing I said something similar
with
um Yan and he beat Yan and that's why I
side with apologize like you can't sleep
on him like he'll find a he's an athlete
I'm trained with him he's good he finds
a way to make it win I'm just saying if
we look at the the numbers and the
Styles that's that's why he's the
underdog Because stylistically by the
it's a very tough idea Yeah by like the
martial arts standpoint I could see how
you would you know
give the give the coverage to Henry with
the with the boxing
his right kicks his best kick
and uh Sterling switches stance a lot so
that gives an opening for that
his uh best punches his right hand and
his best kick is that right kick right
there
that's what my
when I I don't know any of these
Fighters so I did my homework on them
yeah and when I watched all of Henry's
and Sterling the only thing I wrote was
Henry has a crazy right hand
but I think it's leveraged more with
Sterling because he's very very strong
on the ground I think he's gonna try to
go that route because he's not going to
want to no you're assuming that Sterling
can take down the Olympics that's why I
like hearing this though yeah like I
like honestly like I like because this
is how many
more not in the weeds yeah this is how I
learned to be honest like what people
think's gonna happen now I can learn how
to explain things so I like hearing this
welcome what else is for everyone
that's like me talking about computers
so we'll keep it even on that
it's all good nah look he's in his head
look at this background
see what I mean his glasses are tough
like is he fighting why is he breathing
so hard that's what I'm saying because
he's talked so much trash he knows he's
got to back it sometime
I get Henry do your thing yes that guy's
an idiot behind him though
who's the one that was outside the pool
what do you mean he he took a two-year
break and then he's back that's Henry
three year break oh three year break so
we don't like Henry I don't dislike him
I just don't agree with him inspect it I
don't respect that part of it so there's
a group we've chosen because we have to
do this together no I disagree you can
choose whatever you want he'll come find
you she better watch out that's what I'm
saying we need to be together so you
guys can defend me if I have a [__]
meet up
I'm not gonna fight this guy
listen bro he said something about the
pool I don't know I've never been
invited to a pool party I don't know
what the [__] happening here he's a
champ he's from my hometown Arizona so I
I'm from Arizona really yeah Scottsdale
where are you from Tucson nice I went to
a crass Conservatory recording our time
sorry yeah sorry so what are we just
kidding I've been to Tucson it's okay
yeah you actually it's okay that's
actually what I'm reflecting here you
know I I'm just sharing my own ignorance
on my own tiny place
I'm excited about this one yeah I really
hope it doesn't go to decision I want
somebody getting knocked out uh I like
decisions if it displays like their full
like Gambit of style and technique like
if it's back and forth I love a decision
the gentleman with the wings on his back
Ferguson he he fought somebody and they
were just drenched in Blood by the end
of it and then they went to decision and
I thought that was the coolest fight I
don't know if it was Ferguson Ferguson
could be Ben Henderson or Sanchez yeah
or uh the wings are so outrage yeah
that's right oh I got a question while
we're waiting
what fight had you guys jumping out of
your seats like you watched it and
you're like yo I did not expect this to
go this way and this went so much better
than dude we've been watching fights so
long man like there's so many of those
I'll be up tonight
this one
um
I'd have to say come straight to the top
of my head Alexander Gustafson versus
Jon Jones was one of my favorite fights
of all the guy because I watched
Alexander Augustus and that wasn't even
the best find the guard yeah as you'll
see once 165 and there's a young
strapping heavy round there who spent
another heavy with a darsh joke
third third on the lineup on the main
car okay what was the best lineup oh is
that you yeah yes
I would have [__] never if you didn't
give me one of these I would have never
no that John that Jon Jones Augustine's
best fight I've ever seen for me yeah me
too and then it was so at the time it
was also like built because I mean I
watched gustas and prepare for that
fight too I watched him
hurt people in the gym and I was like
how is this guy getting a beat I drove
down there to train with him he knocked
me out just disrespectful
Brandon Travis Brown I spent my camp
with him four rounds and I saw him like
and I was like there's nobody beating
this guy and then Jones went [__] one
the only thing I guaranteed I said this
on the still doing finding the kid at
the time I said I guarantee you Gusman
takes him down ruins like you're stupid
like I've been wrestling a long time man
I've trained with John train with gusson
I'm telling you his chain wrestling his
double leg is insane and he took John
down I think three four times he took
him down and not a lot of people did
that no but uh thing about DC couldn't
take him down it's because he's so good
with his hand yes that he makes you got
to worry about the punch Landing so you
don't think about the takedown and you
don't expect him and Gusman's [__]
big just tall way bigger I was finding a
heavy weight I felt like a welterweight
he's massive man one thing I do like
about this matchup talking about it is
that he's had um
same build
same power like type of power that's a
good point same type of shooting and
wrestling defense
um the difference is I do believe that
uh Henry's boxing is a little bit better
so that's going to be the issue I'd say
way better
that's the difference yeah that's where
it would feel different compared to
Murat but marab's pace is so high that
that overwhelming Pace will support I've
never seen a pace like that man yeah his
that pace against Peter John was insane
that makes me proud to watch the these
30 fibers like
oh to be the main event New Jersey it's
so cool man because the sport did not
this weight class did not exist yeah man
just 10 like we did not exist it was 155
and up when I started I was trying to
put weight on just so I could fight and
I Was preparing to fight Sean shirk
let's put it that way let's put that in
a minute
you think I don't know who that is worse
worse worse teeth because you bring them
up so I'm 19 years old thinking okay I
got to put some weight on to get ready
for this [__] it was such a Savage
he's gonna kill me I gotta get stronger
and then they made my weight class thank
God so I didn't have to face that guy he
was like a shark crazy that's what I
call him the shark also you don't want
him to bite you either he's called a
shark wait shut up yeah that's his
nickname Sean the shark shirt
his teeth are like a mako shark
like if if he was in the water I
wouldn't even want to do you know he was
so [__] good jokes Sean shirt back in
the day it's cool he was cool to watch
he was super Buffy so yeah I looked that
was a guy 155 and up there wasn't even a
discussion and then forget about talking
about women being in the UFC it wasn't
even like no we laughed at it that's how
much this sport has gone up and just
didn't even said David even said on
record women will never fight in the UFC
and then Rhonda came along he's like all
right maybe they will fight in UFC and
then there's 135 what now 125 they're
gonna completely get rid of like three
years ago they're like we're done with
125. now we got women headline in the
card we got 135ers Brandon to me the
best division in the entire UFC a little
bias 35. I don't think a lot of people
would argue right now yeah an argument
35 45 50 has anyone ever hurt themselves
like like doing this [__] right before
now there's a guy Johnny Walker who won
a fight by knockout and started doing
the worm and blew his shoulder out has
never been the same another guy did it
back
backflip off the cage too yeah so it's
happened oh my God yes Johnny Walkers
like a huge Prospect did the worm blew
his shoulder out
now he's ranked number six so he kind of
came back no dog there's no way you
fight somebody when do the worm blow
your [__] out how do you hurt yourself
during the worm it really really
committed to it
look at that reach man
now here here's another step for you Tom
and you know if you believe this stuff
but it's just it is it's pretty black
and white guys over the age of 35 in 155
and under in title fights are 2 and 70.
say that again
so in weight classes in one in weight
class is 155 and under over the age of
35 or 2 and 70 in title fights whoa
that's insane and that's only in UFC
that's not one championship belt toward
WC days that's no you honestly we have
to look at UFC and give the credit to it
look it I mean honestly look at
Demetrius Johnson one over there hasn't
lost since really maybe once yeah the
one lost the first fight over there but
then he around and then what he lost a
round in how many years like you come on
UFC
it's not going to look like that no no
no you know it's so that's the deal UFC
is the best because the the the depth
like you like especially now you're
leveling nobody you got it there's no
easy fights there's literally like one
through fifty like the guy who's 48 is
pretty [__] good I go to pfl you win
a million dollars nobody knows any of
the guys they're all extremely dangerous
but it's still not the level of the
universe and there's a couple guys that
are at that level but not everybody no
and that's the difference the the depth
of the UFC I mean it's just stacked man
all the way around one through [__]
40 are killers especially the lower
weight classes how do you feel about uh
Jake Paul and like the UFC not getting
paid what they should be getting paid do
you feel like that's just
not true or do you think Jake Paul's a
genius because now he's got he's a guy
who's never really fought in his entire
life getting fighters to talk for him
which are relevant so how do you make
yourself relevant the fastest be
irrelevant and have Fighters that are
relevant take your side
it's genius it's just marketing yeah you
guys don't respect him as like a boxer
absolutely not he's a marketing guy he's
a master marketer that picked fights
with guys that he could fight that's not
what Fighters do Fighters don't pick
fights they get told who they're
fighting and fight for a world title
does he want to win a world title no I
think he just wants another show and he
wants to win now for Jake only have six
fights yeah there's some skill there and
he committed to it but when you're
talking about like legit real boxers
like world champions no yeah there's no
comparison yeah like can he and he knows
that he would never fight those he's
fighting guys that are at his level so
you'll get I'll give him respect for
that but he's not like I don't know he
should be fighting yeah like people hate
him like I don't see him versus Canelo
I'm like you're [__] money is six
fights no so you give him some credit
because at least he's risking it because
him his brother could play [__]
Checkers and people are going to tune in
you know but they decided yeah I give
him credit for his marketing right not
changing boxing not his boxing ability
like he fought MMA fighters in boxing
yeah so you think he really doesn't care
playing soccer with a basketball player
yeah and like expecting them to be good
at soccer like their basketball player
we're all gonna be even at that to an
extent because we don't do it a lot
you know and you only got two weapons
we're used to using eight
so you minimize our eight weapons that
we're used to training with our whole
life and you take us down to two now
you've dumbed us down to your level it's
interesting he says he's gonna fight MMA
and pfl huh allegedly yes
I can't wait for this fight
this one or the fight this one
and you guys are both with the guy on
the right I'm with the guy on the left
I'm on the guy with the left and you
know what I have I've been very wrong I
won't be very clear I like both guys but
I just mean by be with I'm confused like
I think he's gonna win yeah uh I think
that aljo
my heart's with aljo
I think aljo gets this is that Keenan
and Kelvin I think he gets it done he's
a good idea but watch the right leg of
Henry and watch the right hand of Henry
those are his big weapons
I'm interested to see how successful
aljo does in the grappling Department
especially when it comes to wrestling
because he surprised me against Peter
John just watch the uh the right hand to
Henry because he doesn't really set his
kicks up aljo
so yeah
kicks the counter yeah just the load the
boxing
and then that right kick he's looking
for that right kick right now
I already love this fight so much more
than the other one I was just coming out
hot
chasing there a little bit
he puts his hands out like kind of like
a Machida
Vegeta or John from a cheetah style
like karate style yeah it's like a
crimes up Karate and wrestling and did
he fight you the same way dumb right
style same stuff interesting differences
though he came forward on me I was
attacking my legs
he was looking to kick see this where it
gets interesting yeah this is what alja
wants though like he wants to create
Graphics yes and be a critical because
now at least he's not getting punched
and kicked yep
but yeah
um we could also see Henry you know what
if he stalls yeah and wins a five round
decision and out grapples him like
outstalls him like a wrestler which is
very possible yeah
yeah is Sterling A Better Grappler
he's a better submission artist
yeah it's different yeah Henry's a
better wrestler
pure wrestler
and uh I would say aljo has better pure
Jujitsu but I would say they're pretty
even if you call it grappling like you
know
an anaconda there that looks kind of
like an anaconda he wants an anaconda
oh Sterling feels it though he's good
he's on the hands to get to his feet
yes so Judo came in as he to end up
mixed martial art which is a gold
medalist in the Olympics George he's
only well I think he's one of three guys
to win a gold medal and compete in the
Olympics but none went on to become
world champion it's so interesting
because Sterling's so good at like
waiting in those moments and recovering
like do you notice how he was in that
position but didn't stop yeah or didn't
like try to get up super fast no he just
was patient yeah that's one of the
things I noticed about Sterling 2 that
makes him really good like he knows
where to rest yeah he's like spending it
see I love fights I guess
good elbow yeah that was a good read
in the office for Al Joe if he keeps
getting these
I like the elbow read by Sterling yeah
that's Gonna Keep Me in there I think
yeah
I'm close see how he's resting here
because he can't name him yeah and he
doesn't have an anaconda he's not
worried about it so like he's not using
any energy here oh
Bob if the scrambles were just key for
aljo
boy's gonna have a tough time taking him
down Against the Cage like this
I figured he'd have a better shot team
down in the center what do you think Dom
it's tough though right with I look at
the fence different this is exactly what
you want to do if you're Sterling what
is the how is the offense different from
the takedown on the floor
what's the difference well you can't you
can't move one's on your feet we're just
ones on your feet but what's the
difference like if he if we take them
both and you put Henry on his back right
now how does the position change
you're still passing the guard you still
have to pass the legs see you still have
to get to this position on the mat so
it's the same so now he can hold him
here
and stay ahead like if he takes him down
he's just stalling right oh I got you
you get what I'm saying it's almost like
a way to to stall yes but not yeah
because you're still winning yeah it's
the same thing if I if Henry takes him
down and just holds him there everybody
goes he's winning he's winning he's
winning
what's the difference on the fence yeah
but people forget you just flip it up
instead of having it down you just flip
the fence up and you use the same tactic
standing that makes sense that's what I
saw that's what sandhagen did to Vera
yes damn man he's about to get his back
here yeah I didn't think he'd give it
not this soon anyway yeah and this is
what aljo wants that's what this makes
but this is what he practiced and you
can see the defense right away he's not
giving it to him
and aljo is a master at get into your
[__] back he's good on the fence man
oh yeah this is brutal oh
uh that first was a good right hand yeah
great right at the end first round it's
tough to score huh I guess aljo
I mean I think so if you're going off
damage hit control
I thought this guy lost that round
sahuda yeah yeah I'd give a first round
to Al Joe that's trouble he's able to
get this back in the first round should
have took four huh four years
I'm gonna meet him one day he's like
yeah come here I was like wait dude I
was just messing around yeah I'm saying
this not as a fact it's my experience of
like having injuries and being off for
three and a half years like there was a
mixture of man I was a little bit rested
but at the same time I didn't like my
feet weren't ready my legs weren't ready
for the kicks my body wasn't ready so
there's like a mixture you're fresh but
you're also not conditioned yeah and so
it's a weird thing like body
conditioning like taking the beating the
actual fight yeah the actual like brunt
Force isn't quite as tough as when
you're on a streak
you've got to have some confidence if
you're freaking out Joe that's a good
round it's a good round but man those
right hands got close for me yeah I
didn't like that
Henry's right hands yeah
and then like how he's running in with
his hands down too Henry does a great
job also of adapting between rounds
making changes
damn
see that's his best kick that right all
right kick is in that's that's gonna be
his biggest weapon not in the right hand
oh
oh good Left Hand by Sterling there
yeah Henry sits so upright
um
what weight class is this
uh bantamweight so uh 135. see that's
his best kick
but he's not sending up he doesn't he he
doesn't he sets it up where that's why
he stands so tall
Ness sets it up
see what I mean like yeah it's it's a
weird like
yeah if I'm if I'm so huda's team you
know he's not laying too much on the
feet he's had more
I thought he would box more me too I
thought he'd have if your team you're
like yeah you have more success when
you're taking him down
but also then you get you get in trouble
with the
all just doing that's making it weird is
he's pushing him back that's why I mean
usually the shorter guys pushing forward
and I think Henry's not going to start
pushing forward until after round three
when are you watch him in other fights
he'll pick around and just turn up any
weights
so they probably have a game plan of
like all right we'll wait and then
really Sprint three and four you take
one off you know
Alex was doing well on the feet
it's also the reach Advantage too is
causing some issues for sudo see how
close those are getting they're getting
close yeah but they're close yeah yeah
and that was those it's only around two
true so it's like when they get close
early they get closer and yes and closer
his reaction time goes down yeah
what's the ref's name
Herb Dean
I heard he's like the favorited one
right or no I know pencil you ask but
I'm asking you now uh
yeah he's kind of the staple now of refs
you know he does the the biggest fights
rest of a tough job
people say the toughest I don't agree
with that
I feel like the fighters have a tougher
chance
call me crazy yeah right
I feel like the brain surgeon has a
tougher gig you know
I wouldn't want to be a judgment or a
tough's job like uh
I feel like Al Joe has a tougher task
oh
that's creative yeah it was well that's
what's cool about Sterling two you can
be a little bit more creative because
um
because of his like wrestling background
and he's so like confident and he's
gonna get up and
so he just kind of lets things flow
Henry starting to come forward now to
your point
yep and that's what he's he has success
when he's going forward the way that
he's doing this and stuff that's that's
trouble yeah for the right kids yeah so
those little things that I'm like make
it a tough match up but right now
especially as the rounds go on yeah and
he's not shooting quite as much as I'd
like I'd like him grappling a little bit
more from Sterling
just to lessen the chances I agree but
that's what I learned I've learned in my
fights as well as I've gotten some
losses like and the game has changed you
have to spend some time
like I was to my point against the fans
too to minimize that 50 50 Battle yes a
free-flowing movement of pure chance
yeah you have to like it's less pure
chance on the fence or on the ground
right oh that right hand landed there
that was nice that's his best punch that
right hand that's what Sterling's gonna
have to watch for the whole fight also
to your point I think it's good to shoot
no one you're not gonna have success
just to keep the guy like that like that
oh did he get hurt there that's weird no
it's just a scramble it was just a
scramble
oh that the time broke there would you
would you give that round to sahuto I
don't know that's close man because the
yeah
that one was a pretty pretty cool so
that one's tough round of score that's
how these fights go though you're gonna
go back when you look at the decision
and go that second round how do you
score it you know it all comes down who
goes to the decision just pray because
we don't oh the judges man there's
literally it's like a toss-up you just
even if you think you know who won it's
a toss-up draftking live odds Sterling
minus 235 now it came in as a dog
it changes throughout the fight yeah
those are like live odds so after two
rounds they have Sterling winning see I
get better after round two so I see that
happening for Henry I can't that's just
how I think if you're anything like me
like I need more than two rounds I need
to download the to download the yeah
like that's why I was so mad like all
right the fight just happened right it's
over yes no it's not like you just
started I'm just cooking like we don't
we just figured each other out now yes
one and one yeah and so then you're
gonna give you're gonna stop this with a
second left while I'm on my feet you
worthless piece I you piece I fought so
hard but I also think it's it's the the
ref's job to know who's in there too the
refs you need to have a relationship
with us yes and you don't then why yes
you're supposed to be keeping me safe
you say right yep and how do you not
know you're right he is he is turning it
up yeah he will definitely is yeah three
four and five he'll turn it up he does a
great job downloading the data and then
going to work damn
oh [__]
hurt him with that knee yeah he did
and he's calm there
uh that one's a little deeper than usual
but the other hand yeah he's safe
his team probably told him too you're
down too look at that back leg
some bruise in there from the kicks see
how he stays down here like you can't do
nothing and it's such a crazy he's good
at standing yeah he does one spot right
yeah
oh
now now it's heating up
good nearby Henry there
boy the key to Henry is going forward
man
oh he's in
boy he doesn't have a chance
Henry's hips are too [__] good man
that's something I'm saying though
you're telling me that David Bailey's
felt any different
for three for you know
he's gonna I promise you
oh he's felt this you know I agree like
and in the in the cardio's there too
yeah so that's the the thing is you're
not going to see Sterling get tired
doing this yeah with this all day this
style yeah Matt that's even if he's
losing here he can lose here all day
even like on the feet moving I'm like oh
that Henry's got a better chance there
yeah you're right but hearing these even
if Henry takes him down like he's he'll
be okay yeah he won't get tired
oh
good great knee
we I have that Matt Steamroller Florala
on uh the shop show and he was just I
was that's what how Sterling look he was
he's going with Murad man he's like his
cardio yeah nice yeah and he was like he
was like you know he's he's hailing
Murad man he's doing well in his car
deals we've never seen him look better
that's a perfect partner yeah it really
is so that helps to get ready for this
darling too yeah
aljo's doing well when it's here isn't
he yeah
but the next two rounds are really
really clutch oof
it's nice to round scare me oh he was
right here at algel Fan those next year
round scare me yep
because they become they become more and
more stand up in the next two rounds yep
oh yeah good shot most guys get taken
down yeah
seeing he's not using energy here he's
not taking damage so this is where I
give
and he doesn't like give his back up
here see this is where I give he's not
hanging on the single leg wasting energy
he is but he's not he's kind of chilling
yeah it's weird right it's like you know
as a fighter like here you go okay stand
up stop bullshitting your coach tells
you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's not
aggressive he's smart like he's not he's
not wasting a lot of time it's brilliant
yeah it is actually they just wait till
it's safe and gets out yep and you can't
name him and how do you punch him
because if you punch him then you let
him out why can't you kneel because he's
a down the down opponent see how he has
four points down if you have three
points so you have to let go of them
isn't that it's so smart
yeah you're right it's so smart and
that's why people don't like him I think
is they think that's like that doesn't
look like it's yeah like a cop-out
almost tactics though it's very
intelligent but how much energy need to
save and how much damage did you take
yeah that's what this thing is you know
God look at that stat
boy he's getting in on the hips but
those [__] Olympic metal Hill hips
manner like trying to take down this
like this yeah like he's so like his
hips are so trouble like that like what
is that thing oh
oh great [__] inside we knew I broke
that down on unlocking Victory if you
guys are curious
would that trip yes
we knew it was happening at least once
tune in on YouTube
God do you think that uh wins the hood
of the round there that take down bro
every time he gets an advantage the Bell
Rings he's turning to
the judging uh criteria no no not that
much but yes because he didn't do I
would say this if it was more close but
I think you guys tell me do you think
that Sterling before that takedown
landed more damage yes so I would say it
should go to Sterling but if you're
gonna give yourself
you had to get that takedown if you're
gonna give yourself a claim so that's
what Henry did well yeah like you gave
yourself a chance now in that round to
to argue yeah so just before if you
didn't get the takedown he won for sure
now you're like yeah you could maybe try
one judge might give it to him right so
those are the little things you kind of
need in these what's the who the looks
tired of it
this is when uh guys like us I'll be
honest guys I can guys like me
yes you're on now yes so this is when
he's going to be the most dangerous yeah
and he's not going to come out tired
he's going to come out dangerous
and probably make some adjustments
because we're ready to be this tired at
this point
and if my question is why is it that
you're turning up is it because you're
studying more and more you know that you
have two rounds to get the job
Championship rounds and you know that
when guys slow down a little openings
happen so the Finish is coming finish
can be there
that was a great cake by aljo to start
that round
watch that right hand mm-hmm
the channel Henry's looking for right
now
right hand right kick
see they gave it to sahula that one some
people gave it to sue though that round
yeah one guy did three
a lot of guys have it Sterling 30 27. I
mean I see Sterling controlling the
fight his way me too you know but
I think these last two rounds are like
gonna make kind of a decided here to
your point because you can tell sahuda
is turning it up yeah he is he's going
to come heavy in the last two and a half
minutes with pressure and try to try to
get to finish in the last two and a half
minutes every round
I like that and look at all the high low
that Sterling's doing that's what makes
it so see how he doesn't know that's
what's helping him oh that was a cool
elbow he doesn't know you don't know if
he's shooting or punching or kicking
earlier don't wait till last 30 seconds
get that trip land it early and let's
get some damage it's hard to grab a hold
of Sterling yes it is like see how he's
he's never sitting still either
and then he switches stance so you threw
a right low kick
now he's in another stance move that
right hand got close there oh good knee
that was his right kick that's what he
does well he times that he tries to time
that right kick when you come in
people forget to those numbers are
staggering people forget too I'll just
been fighting 10 years now man 10
[__] years what do you mean it's just
he's just been he's like he's been
around such a long time man
and where in the UFC oh okay you know
nice just at this level he defended the
answer yeah
I think everything with the glasses
Brendan Frazier that looked like uh they
need a little bread and fridge they look
like Chandler bank I have no idea who
you're talking about is that a YouTuber
no Matthew Perry
oh gotcha do you know watch friends I
mean I've seen it it's not my favorite
what the [__] it's good it's solid you
know it's five friends in an apartment
I'm done talking to you as soon as this
raps I'm never talking to you again
you've been a really good sport man
thank you yeah you're a big you don't
know anything about that I know right
yeah
like on a professional level I mean you
know some stuff I see your notes bro no
I just wrote these all down today like I
said dude I see what you know bro that's
[__]
I see what you wrote does
yes
[Laughter]
laughs
great fight these guys [__] awesome I
agree
I agree 135 let's go
that's how we do it keep trying to catch
that kick and it's just not happening
for him
I'd rather them try to catch it than eat
it on the face thank God he's seeing it
but I don't like the reaching I know
what you're saying yeah
good faints
oh that elbow was nice too that he just
threw formaldo yeah like that those
little things people don't see so
they're in the clinch he throws that out
it gets it gets you to let go of them
for just that second the elbows in the
knees in between are really nice
and this is where Sterling wants to be
like it's so smart again like go ahead
put it in the front headlock yeah Henry
keeps getting there I wonder if he's
thinking eventually
switching to a guillotine or something
there no he wants to get behind him yeah
take the back item yeah just get behind
him and you know wrestling position
he's so long dude look at the position
oh my God bro and notice how his arm's
inside too this is trouble holy [__] wow
now your transition to the back I'm so
blown away by his flexibility
that was insane
I mean he's four seven but insane
[Laughter]
this flexibility you have to do with his
height
shorter distance
like you have Shaq's doing that yo Jesus
Christ
that's a great round for Sterling man
yep that takedown was nuts yeah he's
winning right now yes 100 no doubt he's
controlled this hey uh keto G what's
what's the corner saying
there's no way they're saying he's
winning this fight
wow if I miss Corman hey dude we have to
get a finish here
two to two is insane I mean I don't know
if it's insane with our judging bro
swear to God I wouldn't say it's insane
anymore yeah I'm I'm saying that from a
coach's perspective to say it's tied you
know
well which was here's my thing we don't
know his Camp how do we know that Henry
isn't a Yes Man guy yeah true he
responds to you're the winner you're the
winner you're the winner you're the
winner
yeah you're right so they could just be
telling him what he needs to hear not
what the truth is
98 of the world right now 100 I don't
want to hear the truth I want to hear
what makes me feel good inside the way
you tie that in with politics is so
nonsense dude nice combo sorry and do
you want to put one of your spiels up
that was it I know that was the segue
then I missed it but I think we did all
the reads they did zoom in throwing in
there the monarchs
the newest coach you can get him in
England
they're my people check them out
monarchs thank you monorex where are
they at in England
um what's going out there tell them
we're telling them right now
we're telling our guys right now at
monaracks pull them up I'm in London
m-o-n-t-e-r-e-x
it's my guys taking good care of MMA
fighters
I'll rock a leather jacket around London
Montour X
yeah
Monterey X
somebody was at the Sylvan Learning What
ethnicity are you Korean that's the
first Corinthians that's the one that's
good you're on the same level right now
bro I'm horrible math and spelling so I
like how so those pressuring and heading
off he's not following us that's what
he's doing well
um what I like what Sterling does is the
second he throws a punch he just shoots
or he exits it's like it's so nice we
can run yeah yeah it's so nice oh he's
trying to go knock him out look how good
a shape he's in phenology both of them
yeah
come on
I mean even that like I remember your
your coach always tell you don't turn
your back don't turn yourself he's
turned his back he always turns his back
it's like he finds a way to use it to
almost stay safe yeah it's weird
remember when Alistair over him was like
one of the first to do it he's like
running you're right yeah he looks so
weird it did like why is he running
and it worked it worked and then he
knocks you out like what the hell
and then also Sterling's always circling
he's not going straight back that's
what's really helping him a lot
oh nice chin
it's me just seeing if Alger gets a take
down here late in the fifth
oh good left hand got him right in the
schnoz sickle on that one
yeah
I know it's either said than done yeah
I'm saying take down dude get the
earlier take down now what's the take
I'm gonna do it he has to knock him out
yeah takedown is just buying the other
guy time
and now he's he's Landing more pressure
it's two to two though
but again if coach could just be saying
that's given the right mindset like well
I mean he could be right that's a thing
nobody knows really right but it could
be four zero that's how I look at it
from coaching like all right nobody
really knows so what do we got to tell
my guide
to win yep and that's it nothing else
matters Judo just looked at the clock I
saw that because he knows he's got two
minutes to get the Finish yep in his
head yep not I'm tired you know some
people can see it both ways but he
doesn't look tired at all yeah there's a
big difference in him looking at the
clock and then when somebody Jones will
get the clock when we saw Woodley look
at the club yes do you know what I'm
saying now exactly yeah
but through those takedowns his intros
are insane
or Sterlings you mean yes yes his
defense is to this we knew those defense
would be good but
dude just just so we're clear DraftKings
has the live odds right now minus 550
for Sterling so that's pretty I mean the
numbers are on Sterling's side big time
but again with these judges you never
know yep you really don't oh hell no
it's just crazy like if they gave it to
so who though I would be like oh well
because if you give let's say because
that second round was closed that last
round maybe I could see maybe it's the
Judo so you have two and four I wouldn't
agree if they gave it to sudo I think
Sterling's one up till now me too but I
could just saying yeah
[__] it up and give two for maybe this
fifth
and he's pressuring a lot in his fifth
he gets his takedown as trouble oh [__]
no he has his back
see and when you lose that you can't
lose the fifth no so this is a bad look
for Sterling
I don't like I don't like that he took
off the fifth but I still think he won
but I don't like it he took off the
fifth
and those judges who are on the fence
it's definitely not
good
he's gonna throw him for big points
right now over shoulder
oh just in time he turned
good fight they should've done the Don
fry thing they're going to start wailing
on each other
yeah great fight I I would give it to
Sterling
but
I just I love like after like you watch
two human beings like try to kill each
other right is the belt it's just it's
just so cool of it
I'm surprised because I'm so like I
don't I think that I would be is like if
I I wouldn't want to talk to you or even
look at you after I'm done fighting it
you have to respect because you both
want you both risk the same thing trust
me it's over your show relief you would
I promise you on everything holy you
would hug that person that person will
be part of your DNA for the rest of your
life you can't help it it's like a weird
disgusting family member that you hate
and like at the same time because the
only person that can share that common
experience with you oh that makes sense
so you create this weird Bond it's a
weird thing I wouldn't say I just I I
didn't mean in like a district you said
you spit on them
nothing but disrespect disrespect from
you to be honest see if you didn't
stutter it would have hurt more
I think they're going to give it to
Henry for some odd reason dude don't do
it and the numbers are so on Aldo side
too like I don't know don't do that to
our sport yeah don't do it they're gonna
do it bro and people are gonna be pissed
you out there as long as they do it I'm
just getting up and leaving I'm not even
wrapping up the show
don't tell me that you guys know about
this Sport and that first round for
Alger all day had his back went
once dominant took him down
and that was a good tahuto too if aljo
wins that was in a [__] assudo he
looked pretty good
wouldn't you agree no you didn't like
yeah I mean he looked wrong he looked
healthy and rested and not Rusty no no
no man this is it and if you train
you're ready
now look at the face who's got more
damage right if you're not even close
right yeah you'd say Henry has more
damage on the face I would say Sterling
won yeah me too you know but we'll see
I don't have a mark look at his face and
if damage decides what's it split yeah
yeah but they always win 9.7
Al Joe won baby they got it right close
bro that was close Split Decision wow I
don't know crazy now aljo goes to 45 and
then marab's gonna come up
they have a marab uh sugar that's a
that's a tough one for sugar but he's
gonna win that one sugar he could very
easily could and now honestly he'll go
up and so who the one Sterling uh
O'Malley could still happen
that's the thing yeah that that could
still happen so I think Sterling goes up
and then we'll see that
yeah and also to your point of the
entertainment side of things with Murad
being you know he doesn't really do the
entertainment and he doesn't want to
fight his teammate
so UFC might be like man we'll just do
you know
suhudo and
sugar mm-hmm
[Music]
you see that George show some [__]
respect most title fight wins in
bantamweight history Donna Cruz tied for
second
aljo just tied this man
still want to spit on him
first of all everybody knows I was
talking [__] when he wasn't listening I
don't even talk [__] oh there's Tim
yeah it's a smart person to call out
he's got the red coat on and to get it
done soon too because marab's gonna
fight probably uh Corey sandahagan think
so yeah
what's he saying keto George
yeah
and I wrote in my notes the Striking was
good too very strong ground game
[Laughter]
nailed it God Dana's in shape man
yeah
let's go
do that just beat the Jackson jacket is
sick he just comes and punches him
straight in the back of that
sugar knows the game the electricity
comes right in I'm gonna be honest I
didn't think I took the shirt off yeah
he's got the WWE going yeah he does
there's the WWE ladies and gentlemen
sold now get this the fight's actually
going to be real still so even though
this
might be WWE is it we'll never know
that's that's why they made it happen
who put on his jacket robbed it
he's just in his jacket in the back I
was coaching I hope he wears at home
also he's like this thing is sick he's
like yes
stylistically tough fight for sugar
stand-ups high level though so
his ground game is pretty I like it
Tim's working on it with him sugars
it's good it's not it's not Al Jos
there's not enough hours in the day no
he tried to take his he took his jacket
back
yeah he's like don't take my friend's
jacket did you hear me oh he thought it
was Rob's Jack and Rob's like I wasn't
wearing this [__] I was just messing
around
haha
did you hear it looked like Sean was
like dude I'm just taking my jacket back
she was like this is my jacket dumbass
that's so funny
yeah I like that
oh Cece
yeah the fight made itself
Sean Shelby's like thanks fellas
what's he say now keto George
pretend to be known but the Funkmaster
he said step in the cage I'll drag your
ass see that's what I mean you either go
WWE or you keep it real yeah he's saying
you know what keep it real kind of works
too though you know especially in the
champ and those guys because that other
guy can do it you know yeah let him do
the entertainment thing you keep it real
and still works you just gotta win
correct and he's been winning it's all
good that's why you don't need to do it
especially when you champ let the other
guys do it for you but then I think all
right what if you're playing the game
and you're putting all that pressure and
then you win too yeah that's what I'm
saying that's the next that's what's
happening with a lot of guys they're
doing both and then they're doubling
down and making all the money some guys
are doing half
yep have to work part of the work is
putting all that pressure on yourself
is there a world where Hulu retires
right now
he retired before why wouldn't he retire
now
yeah he's not gonna fight for a title
you think you can go back down the queue
I doubt it no I don't know why would he
do that yeah
that big bump on his cheek I think
that's one that was a head bunt when he
moved up because that was risky to go
back down the line and face guys it's
murderous real man it's a monster
they're all really good and
it's not for a title yeah so you got to
really like want to fight you gotta be
fighting you gotta love it yeah
what's he say in Keto
his Corner said he won uh around three
four and five you were right
see and that's what I mean
a little bit the fight yeah a little bit
you need new glasses here I just kind of
have I haven't I don't think I didn't
think it was debatable do you control
the mics over there what's up do you
control the mics of it I do yeah cut
yours off
I did though I mean as a fan I'm not a
fighter as a fan though you used her
yeah I know it's cool man
you guys know what's up so yeah but as a
fan I was like don't go and make
yourself wrong after you try to prove
yourself you guys are Fighters you guys
were Fighters yeah but you're a fan yeah
that's a fan I thought yeah you're
allowed to have a completely clueless
point it's allowed it's I mean just
being dumb and the judges into it we're
the only ones that are right man
don't be surprised if we retires here no
no he's good
he'll get somebody good in the top you
know top ten oh big time yeah he's still
got money to make so for sure so okay
questions
how far down does he have to drop after
losing this fight
uh it's uh that that's what it gets
tough with those rankings says he's been
out three years comes back loses
uh and those other guys been working
they have you know streaks and wins well
that's what happened to me I lost the
title and then guess what they made me
do
you go to the bottom of the line yep I
faced I think a guy that wasn't even
ranked on the fight pass on the main
event of the Fight Pass prelims which is
by the way you fought the Asian fella I
fought
um Casey Kenny that's right
and then uh beat him and then I bought
somebody ranked after that in the top
10. and then beat him and then I had to
face another guy in the top ten and then
lost to him and now I'm still in the top
ten but now we're there that was on your
recent comeback before that remember we
had the long left you came back didn't
you finally yeah that's right there was
no fight win streak yeah five finishes
yeah that's what I'm thinking of your
first comeback
respect to both guys though yeah that
was an awesome fight I loved how they
held it down for the division
um
sick I mean look at the top eight in the
division Davis O'Malley
to myself and I just am there because uh
yadong just fought so I was seven but
since he fought he moves up above one
and then as guys keep fighting they'll
keep moving yep
yeah I mean 145 too that Umar they're
making Madoff is a problem he's a beast
yeah it gets trouble yeah well
that's the thing everybody in that top
15 can or top yeah Styles right
anybody can get it done that's it yeah
that's it
that's it it's literally in the top 15
of each division I feel like anybody can
be a but
depends what style yes style even Adrian
Jana is at 12 is a [__] Savage man
even just lost to Rod yeah tough fight
from a stylistically tough fight for him
there's a much better matchups for him
in the top 10.
I was getting out of fights though boys
appreciate you doing it Dom you saved
the day I owe you brother save the
[__] day I hope you guys go I'm glad
you were here we really opened our eyes
no it was great man you did a great job
George it was good to see the ignorance
of the people listen I mean George and
Chin man and don't think it's just for
fighting it could be in any any vertical
you wanted
uh I love it that's it fellas that was
fun thank you guys thank you guys thank
you thanks for tuning in love yourself
oh you walk out a tip we are out of here